Hello, listener.
My name is Jason.
I am one-third of the machine you have tuned in to listen to.
Speaking of machinery, those two tools are on their way in.
Sit tight, turn it up.
Here it comes.
Welcome to Smartless.
Hey, guys, guess what?
你好，听众朋友。我叫杰森。我是你收听的这个节目的三位成员之一。说到机器，那两个工具正在进来的路上。坐稳了，把音量调大。它要来了。欢迎收听 Smartless。嘿，伙计们，你们猜怎么着？
What is it, John?
There's our live episodes out now on YouTube with Jonah Hill from the Avalon.
Our live episode.
How can people find it?
It's at YouTube slash Smart.
Is that right?
Say it again?
I wasn't writing.
是什么事，约翰？我们在 YouTube 上推出我们的现场录制节目了，嘉宾是来自阿瓦隆剧场的乔纳·希尔。我们的现场节目。大家怎么找到它？网址是 YouTube 斜杠 Smart。对吗？再说一遍？我刚才没记。
Yeah, it's at YouTube.com slash smartless.
And you can watch it,
and it's a live show at the Avalon with Joan Hill.
So you can see us instead of heroes.
This is correct.
All right, well, thanks for the housekeeping there.
Anyway, let's get back to things.
By the way, what do you guys think of my shirt?
对，网址是 YouTube.com 斜杠 smartless。你可以去看，这是我们在阿瓦隆剧场与乔纳·希尔合作的现场秀。所以你们可以看到我们，而不是只能听到声音。完全正确。好吧，谢谢你刚才播报这些实用信息。总之，让我们言归正传。对了，你们觉得我的衬衫怎么样？
I do notice you're wearing a NASA hat today.
Are you feeling excited about the Artemis, too?
Isn't that wild?
Let's talk about that.
Why is everybody freaking out about that?
Because we've been going like traveling to Mars and shit.
No.
Well, but like we did the moon loop, did the moon landing is 68, 9, something like that?
我注意到你今天戴了一顶美国宇航局的帽子。你对“阿耳忒弥斯2号”感到兴奋吗？不是很酷吗？我们来聊聊这个。为什么每个人都对它大惊小怪？因为我们之前一直在说什么去火星之类的话题。不对。好吧，不过就像我们曾经绕月飞行过，登月是在68、9年左右吧，差不多？
Yeah, 69, yeah.
They're not even landing on the moon.
They're just going to kind of do a little lasso around it.
They're pussies.
But it's just like, why is everyone like, oh, God, it.
No, I think it's amazing what they're doing.
They're slingshitting it, by the way.
I'm just saying, like, help me understand.
对，69年，没错。他们甚至不是在月球上着陆。他们只是打算绕着它转一圈。真是一群懦夫。但这就好比，为什么每个人都一副“天哪，太厉害了”的样子。不，我觉得他们做的事情很了不起。顺便说一句，他们是在借力飞行。我只是说，帮我理清一下。
Yeah, no, well, because it's the farthest anybody's,
been ever. Is that right?
I think so. I think it's the far
humans, yeah, from Earth. From Earth, yeah.
Because we're traveling around the backside
of it as opposed to landing on the front of it?
That's correct, yeah. Well, that seems like
they're reaching for a record there, you know?
对，没错，因为这是人类去过的最远的地方。是这样吗？我想是的。我想这是人类距离地球最远的一次。离地球，对。因为我们是绕到月球背面去，而不是在正面着陆？没错，是的。好吧，听起来他们像是在刷新某种纪录，你知道吗？
That's like not going to Jason's house, but just stopping
at Will's house. Yeah, I mean, I just
don't know if that's something... It feels like
the equivalent of Oscar Bate.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, what if they did? How about this? What if they do
that one loop, right?
So they qualify for Frist.
这就好比不打算去杰森家，而只是在威尔家门口停一下。对，我的意思是，我只是不知道这算不算……感觉就像是奥斯卡公关的把戏。对，对。我是说，如果他们这么做呢？这样如何？如果他们完成那一圈飞行，对吧？从而获得了参赛资格。
And then when they come back around,
fucking land the thing.
Like, you know,
and drive the buggy around again
and hit another golf shot,
that'll be really sensational.
I'm going to try to get you an email address
so you can send this in.
然后等他们绕回来的时候，把那玩意儿他妈的降落下去。就像，你知道的，再次开着月球车四处转转，再打一次高尔夫球，那才叫真的轰动。我试着给你弄个邮箱地址，好让你把这个建议发过去。
I'm sure they're looking for ideas over there.
Of course.
Wait, Jay, but I think they're,
I think the idea is to collect more information
so that the next one they can land on the moon.
Again.
Yeah, I think.
What about if they put, like,
我敢肯定他们正在那边寻找创意呢。当然。等等，杰伊，但我认为他们的想法是收集更多信息，这样下一次他们就能在月球上着陆了。再次着陆。对，我想是这样。如果在上面建个像那种小树屋之类的东西会怎么样？
build like a little treehouse on it or something like that.
Well, I think they're talking about that.
Yeah, they're talking about like colonizing a little tiny thing
so that you can launch from there to Mars.
Would you ever sign, if you, would you ever do one of these rocket launches?
Like, what's his face that Amazon did?
Jack Bezos.
Right, he sent some people up.
好吧，我想他们正在讨论这个。对，他们正在讨论建立一个小小的殖民地，这样你就可以从那里出发去火星。如果让你去，你会参加这种火箭发射吗？就像亚马逊那个谁做的那样？杰夫·贝佐斯。对，他送了一些人上去。
Would you ever do that?
I would, yeah.
Really?
Yeah, absolutely.
Wouldn't you?
Willie?
I think I probably would.
I mean, wouldn't that be cool?
你会参加吗？我会的，真的吗？对，绝对会。难道你不会吗？威利？我想我大概会吧。我的意思是，那不是很酷吗？
You wouldn't push out like a day before and go, well, hang on.
I wouldn't pay for it.
I never pay for it.
Right.
Yeah, well, nobody paid for it.
Did those people pay for it?
Only in dignity.
难道你不会在出发前一天突然退缩，然后说，嗯，等等。我才不会花钱呢。我绝不会花钱。对。好吧，其实没人花钱。那些人花钱了吗？只付出了尊严。只付出了尊严。
The Bezos people, they pay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like $250,000 or some shit to go.
Really?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's crazy money.
You can go up and leave the atmosphere and come back down.
Yeah, to feel weightlessness.
贝佐斯那些人，他们是要付钱的，对，对，对。上去一趟得花大概25万美元左右。真的吗？天哪。对，对，对。这简直是疯了。你可以上去脱离大气层然后又返回。对，去体验失重的感觉。
Wouldn't that be fun?
Well, I'd love to get Neil DeGrasse-Tie.
Jason back on just to finish up that answer he was forming for me.
I know.
I think it's all pretty cool.
I mean, I'm not obsessed with it, but I think it's pretty damn cool.
Yeah, they had some toilet problems on the Artemis, too.
Did you read that?
那不是很酷吗？好吧，我很想请尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森再来一次，好把刚才他为我构思的那个回答做个结尾。我知道。我觉得这一切都挺酷的。我是说，我并没有着迷，但我觉得这真的酷毙了。对，他们在“阿耳忒弥斯2号”上遇到了一些厕所问题。你读到那篇报道了吗？
Yeah.
Yes.
I had a toilet problem this morning.
Let me tell you this.
Jason, you know, Jason, you could never go because they don't have a shower.
tremendous toilet.
Because they don't have a shower next to the toilet up there, so you never be able to go.
You can't shower immediately out.
对。是的。我今天早上就遇到了厕所问题。我跟你说这个。杰森，你知道的，杰森，你永远也去不了，因为那里没有淋浴间。那里的厕所太棒了。因为他们在太空的厕所旁边没有淋浴间，所以你永远也去不了。你不能马上冲澡。
after a BN?
No.
Well, I'm out.
Yeah, of course you're out.
I got to feel fresh, you guys.
As I explore the universe.
Can you use a flushable wipe up there since there's no flushing?
I bet.
在拉完大号之后？没有。好吧，那我出局了。对，你当然出局了。我得让自己感觉神清气爽，伙计们。当我在探索宇宙的时候。既然没有冲水设备，你能在上面用那种可冲入马桶的湿巾吗？我敢说可以。
I'm sorry.
Wait, you know what else?
But I've been watching that new documentary, the Bob Lazar S4 thing.
No, what's that?
I like a new documentary.
Yeah, so you've got to see Bob Lazar.
You know Bob Lazar, who worked at Area 51 and has been talking about it for decades.
我敢说。对不起。等等，你知道还有什么吗？我一直在看那个新纪录片，关于鲍勃·拉扎尔 S4 的那个。没有，那是什么？我喜欢看新纪录片。对，所以你得去看看鲍勃·拉扎尔。你知道鲍勃·拉扎尔吗？他曾在51区工作，几十年来一直在谈论这件事。
And nobody believes him, and he's like, I keep, he has drawings, he has memories, it's, it's fascinating.
And he, he, he, he, uh, it's called, uh, it's called, never mind, we look up at, it's called
S4, the Bob Lizarre story. Okay. So, oh, go ahead, sorry. No, keep going, I'm saying so.
Yeah, so, so, so the, um, he went into, as, he used to work there. I know, I'm hurrying.
I know, I'm hurrying. He went into, he used to work there. And there was this long hanger of, of, of, like, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of,
parts of alien spacecraft.
I like getting involved.
I mean, I'm sweating.
没有人相信他，而他却像是在坚持，他有图纸，有记忆，这，这太迷人了。而且他，他，他，他，呃，这叫做，这叫做，算了，我们查一下，这叫 S4：鲍勃·拉扎尔的故事。好吧。哦，你接着说，对不起。不，你继续，我的意思是。对，所以，所以，所以那个，嗯，他走进了，因为他以前在那里工作。我知道，我在快点讲。我知道，我在快点讲。他走进去，他以前在那里工作。这里有一个长长的机库，里面有，有，有，有，外星飞船的零件。我喜欢参与进来。我是说，我都出汗了。
Literally sweating.
So there's a long hanger.
Yeah, no, there's a hanger with different sections,
and each section has different parts of alien spacecraft
that they've collected over the years.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah, that doc we were talking about,
I don't know if we were talking about it,
字面意义上的出汗。所以有一个长长的机库。对，不，那是一个有不同区域的机库，每个区域都存放着他们多年来收集的外星飞船的不同零件。对，这太疯狂了。对，我们刚才谈论的那部纪录片，我不知道我们当时是不是在谈论它。
on the podcast or away, but the age of disclosure,
you know, James Clapper and John Brennan,
they're talking about, like, yeah,
yeah, we have been doing crash site recovery
for years.
Yes, forever.
And Bob Lazar has been talking about it
way before they have.
是在播客上还是私下里，但你知道“披露时代”这部片子，詹姆斯·克拉珀和约翰·布伦南，他们谈到，是的，是的，我们多年来一直在进行坠毁地点的回收工作。是的，永远都在。而鲍勃·拉扎尔谈论这个的时间比他们早得多。
And Doni said, well, to myself, self,
why don't we know about all this
in a much more mainstream way?
And the answer is, is simply,
it would be too unsettling and disruptive to society.
I think now it's slowly coming.
I think now it's slowly coming out
because I think we can handle it now.
多尼对我说，对自己说，为什么我们没有以一种更为主流的方式了解这一切？答案很简单，因为这对社会来说会过于令人不安和具有颠覆性。我想现在它正在慢慢浮出水面。我想现在它正在慢慢被揭露，因为我认为我们现在能够承受了。
Do you think we're helping
by having little conversations like this on a podcast?
Absolutely.
This is having a major impact.
Conditioning the public?
This is,
This is helping turn the tide for sure.
Or not for us holding their hand
你觉得我们在播客上进行这样的小规模对话是在帮忙吗？绝对是。这产生了重大影响。在对公众进行心理调适吗？这，这无疑有助于扭转局面。或者说，不是我们在手把手地引领他们。
into something unsettling.
People would be shocked.
Us just having this sort of really loose
anecdotal conversation where we can't even remember
the names of the goddamn documentary
is having a real effect.
And not even know that mission of Artemis too.
Yeah, exactly.
走向某种令人不安的事实。人们会大吃一惊的。我们只是进行这种非常随意的、充满道听途说的对话，甚至连那部该死的纪录片的名字都记不住，却产生了真正的效果。甚至连“阿耳忒弥斯2号”那个任务都不知道。对，没错。
Not even knowing.
Well, you know, listen,
this is all good stuff.
Talk about a segue.
I think this fella,
might have a nice perspective for us on this.
Now, this is today, it brings us a voice of the current,
the relevant, the forward and the fresh.
甚至都不知道。好吧，你知道，听着，这些都是好料。说起承上启下。我觉得这位老兄，可能会对这个话题给我们带来一个不错的视角。现在，今天，他为我们带来了当代、相关、前沿且新鲜的声音。
Okay, this comedian, artist, and media entrepreneur
was born in Egypt, lives in New York,
spends his time delivering us one of the most viewed
and talked about online interview shows around.
His work has gathered billions of views,
achieved acclaim from New York Times,
GQ, New Yorker, Vanity,
as well as receiving multiple Webby nominations.
好吧，这位喜剧演员、艺术家兼媒体创业者出生于埃及，住在纽约，他的时间大多用来为我们带来当今浏览量最高、讨论度最高的在线访谈节目之一。他的作品获得了数十亿次的浏览量，并得到了《纽约时报》、《GQ》、《纽约客》、《名利场》的好评，还获得了多项威比奖提名。
Please welcome.
Not a fancy schmancy triple A-list celebrity type, you two.
No, no, this is a man of the people, a voice of the Hattinan,
a guy with some helpful hot takes, the host of Subway takes, Mr. Karim Rama.
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Aliens are real.
The truth is out there.
掌声欢迎。不是那种浮华的三流 A 级明星类型，你们俩。不，不，这是一位来自人民的男子，曼哈顿之声，一个有着实用的热门观点的家伙，街头访谈（Subway Takes）的主持人，卡里姆·拉玛先生。哦，嘿。你好。外星人是真的。真相就在那里。
Right?
Do you think there's a chance this is a real thing?
that we're going to the moon?
No.
That we're going to do a lap.
That part's true.
We're in mid-lap right now.
No, I mean that like we're go, like that the rocket's even in space.
对吧？你觉得这有可能是真实存在的吗？就是我们要去月球这件事？没有。我们要绕它转一圈。那部分是真的。我们现在就在半圈的途中。不，我的意思是，就像我们要去，就像火箭甚至在太空中。
Who knows if it's even in space?
Oh.
Oh, let's go all the way back there.
What do you mean?
What are you saying?
Are you, do you think that maybe we filmed the landing on the moon in a soundstage?
Look, I am not a scientist, but I saw that the curve of the rocket, like when it was
going in space kind of looks like it's not going up,
谁知道它是不是真的在太空中？哦。哦，让我们一直追溯到那个时候。什么意思？你在说什么？你，你觉得有没有可能我们是在摄影棚里拍摄的登月画面？看，我不是科学家，但看到火箭的弧线时，当它飞向太空时，看起来有点像它不是在往上飞，
it's going into the ocean.
I'm just saying, I saw one video about this.
If the arc continued, it's going to plummet.
It's just going to go into those?
No, no, no.
A short social media video is all I need.
I think that arc is to offset the rotation of the Earth.
That's right.
而是掉进海洋里。我只是说，我看过一个关于这个的视频。如果这个弧度继续下去，它就会坠毁。它只会掉进那些地方？不，不，不。一个简短的社交媒体视频就是我所需要的全部。我觉得那个弧线是为了抵消地球的自转。没错。
It looks like it's going straight up, but it's not.
It's going against the curve of the Earth.
But the Earth is flat, so that makes no sense.
Okay, thank you for joining us.
I'll see you guys there.
No, I don't believe at disclaimer.
I don't believe any of that.
I believe in the real world is round.
它看起来像是直直向上飞，但其实并不是。它是逆着地球的弧度在飞。但地球是平的，所以这根本说不通。好吧，谢谢你加入我们。回头见。不，我不相信这种免责声明。我不相信那些鬼话。我相信现实世界是圆的。
So you don't think there's any possibility
that there is life outside Earth
or sort of intelligent beings
and that perhaps they may have crashed on this Earth
a couple of times and that the government is aware.
No, I fully believe that.
I've had extraterrestrial experience.
I'm surprised none of you guys have.
所以你认为地球之外存在生命或者某种智能生物的可能性为零？而且他们可能已经在这个地球上坠毁过好几次了，而政府是知情的。不，我完全相信这一点。我有过外星人的经历。我很惊讶你们当中竟然没有人有过。
Welcome back to our episode.
Oh, Thomas.
No.
You guys haven't had extraterrestrial experiences?
Well, I did mention...
No comment.
Let's hear what...
Tell us yours first.
欢迎回到我们的节目。哦，托马斯。没有。你们从来没有过外星人经历吗？好吧，我确实提到了……无可奉告。让我们听听……先给我们讲讲你的经历吧。
Yeah.
Now, see, now it sounds fake, but I saw an alien in the bushes.
Mm-hmm.
But I was a kid, like, probably like 12.
And I just saw it.
And it just looked at me and it said the word zone is Z-O-N-E.
And then I kind of just like said that a couple times.
that a couple times and then it just ran away.
对，现在，你看，听起来可能很假，但我曾在灌木丛里看到过一个外星人。嗯。但我当时是个孩子，大概12岁吧。我一眼就看到了它。它只是看着我，然后说了一个词，那个词是 Z-O-N-E（地带）。然后我大概就像那样重复了几遍。重复了几遍，接着它就跑掉了。
Was it the classic almond-shaped eye
and head, tear drop head kind of thing?
It was similar to that, but not as exaggerated.
It was more like it looked like,
it just kind of looked like a weird-looking,
maybe it was a weird-looking guy.
Yeah.
It might have just been a neighbor.
是那种经典的杏仁状眼睛和脑袋、泪滴状脑袋的那种东西吗？跟那个差不多，但没有那么夸张。它更像是，看起来，它只是有点像个长相奇怪的家伙，也许它是个长相奇怪的人。对。可能只是个邻居。
Was he small?
Yeah, it was a small, weird-looking guy,
but he was kind of green and big, huge eyes.
I mean, it looked like an alien that you think about.
And when he said that,
do you feel like he was telling you, like, get it?
in the zone, like lock in, like it was encouragement, like, hey, man, get into the zone.
Study harder in school.
他个子很小吗？对，是个个子很小、长相奇怪的家伙，但他有点发绿，眼睛大得吓人。我的意思是，他看起来就像你想象中的那种外星人。当他说出那个词时，你觉得他是想告诉你，比如：进入状态（Get in the zone），集中注意力，就像是在鼓励你，嘿，老兄，进入状态吧。在学校里要更用功学习。
Yeah.
Now, all right, so then I'll half joking aside and all that, would you be surprised if
there was a mainstream declaration from the government that we have in fact, we can confirm
that this is more than a possibility and kind of get ready for this multi-year kind of trick.
rollout information to really make this legitimate and substantial.
Like they're here.
I think the impact on society, I think it would destroy society.
I think more so than like anything else because I think religion like would crumble.
好吧，那，半开玩笑到此为止，如果政府发表了一项主流声明，称我们事实上已经可以确认这不仅仅是一种可能性，然后开始进行这种长达数年的精心策划的。信息发布，来让这一切变得合法和实质化，就像他们真的来了一样，你会感到惊讶吗？我认为它对社会的影响，我认为它会摧毁社会。我觉得这比其他任何事情都更严重，因为我认为宗教将会崩溃。
Science would be gone.
Yeah.
But but like what about what somebody said last night that, you know, there's a,
What if there's a possibility, let's say,
that there's a group of wise men there in the government
that is trying to figure out the best responsible way
in which to condition the public
to this inevitable reveal.
科学将会消失。对。但是，但是昨晚有人说过的话呢，你知道的，有一个。比方说，有没有这样一种可能：政府里有一群智者，正试图找出一种最佳且负责任的方式，来让公众适应这一不可避免的真相大白。
And that, you know, Stephen Spielberg's next movie,
it's coming out at the end of this year,
is called Disclosure.
Like, it's going to be an enormous film.
And it is about, from what I can gather from the trailer,
the public finally being told.
Right.
And it's probably funded by the CIA.
而且，你知道的，史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的下一部电影将于今年年底上映，片名叫《披露》（Disclosure）。听起来，这将是一部宏大的电影。从我从预告片中了解到的情况来看，这部电影讲的是最终向公众吐露真相。没错。而且它可能是由中央情报局（CIA）资助的。
I'm not even kidding.
And I'm saying maybe this group was,
they pulled Spielberg in and said,
hey, listen, could you help us out with,
could you cover the pop culture end of this?
And just start to...
We need you to feed that, like,
give the Pablam to the people so that they can kind of...
我甚至不是在开玩笑。我是说，也许这个组织，他们把斯皮尔伯格拉进来说，嘿，听着，你能帮个忙吗？你能负责流行文化这一块吗？然后开始……我们需要你投喂这些，就像给大众喂食婴儿米糊一样，好让它们能够……
They're not so ambushed when it comes out and it's, you know...
I think people, no matter what the news is,
they'll just keep scrolling.
I mean, there could be aliens among us right now.
They'll just keep scrolling.
I think that's the conditioned, you know?
You don't think it's going to...
It won't jarred them out of it and they'll think,
当真相大白、而且是……时，他们不至于感到那么措手不及。我觉得人们，无论新闻是什么，他们都会继续刷手机。我的意思是，现在我们中间可能就有外星人。他们还是会继续刷手机。我觉得这就是被训练出来的习性，你知道吗？你不觉得这会……这不会让他们猛然惊醒，然后心想，
no, that's probably not real.
I don't think so.
No, I think people will, like, seek out alien porn
and, like, they'll do, like, it'll be more...
Porn is always on the cutting edge of everything.
They're always first on everything.
I mean, even engagement with, you know, ghosts and stuff.
It's always porn.
不，那大概不是真的。我不这么认为。不，我觉得人们会，比如，去搜索外星人色情片，然后，比如，他们会做，这会更……色情内容总是走在所有事物的前沿。他们总是最先涉足一切。我是说，甚至是对幽灵之类的东西的关注。永远都是色情内容。
Porn's always first.
But I think that this movie is probably crazy timing.
And, like, and the launch, like, I do think the CIA's,
I sound so...
I probably sound like the most insane guests you ever had.
No, no, no.
Okay, good, okay, good, okay.
We haven't aired those, but...
色情内容永远是第一位的。但我觉得这部电影的时机简直疯狂。而且，像那个发射，我是说，我真的觉得中情局的，听起来我……我听起来可能像是你们接待过的最疯狂的嘉宾了。不，不，不。好吧，很好，好吧，很好，好吧。我们还没把那些播出去，但是……
But I think that the CIA has been known to use, like,
movies to, like, promote, like, oh, we're going to war in the Middle East.
By the way, they would always do, you know,
the government would make film, they would decide what kinds of films should be made
at times of war, second world wars.
And to sort of, you know, garner support and get people,
lifts people's spirits and get them feeling patriotic and that's not new.
All right.
但我认为中情局历来有利用电影来宣传的习惯，比如，我们要去中东打仗。顺便说一句，他们总是会这么做，你知道的，政府会制作电影，他们会决定在战争时期应该制作什么样的电影，比如第二次世界大战。以此来，你知道的，争取支持，振奋人心，让人感到爱国，这并不是什么新鲜事。好吧。
So, Mr.
Where to begin?
I mean, where to begin?
What kind of statement is over?
How do we claw back?
Start us, take us, walk us towards, you know, you're now sort of this, you know,
one of these forward voices in pop culture today.
那么，先生。从何说起？从何说起？我是说，从何说起？这算什么开场白？我们该如何扳回一局？带个头，带带我们，引导我们走向，你知道的，你现在可以说是，你知道的，当今流行文化中这些前沿的声音之一。
How did it all kind of start?
Did you, was this a goal?
You started in Minneapolis, yes.
You got a journalism degree, maybe, yes.
And then a business degree?
Yeah, that was a failure.
I didn't finish that.
And then you travel out to New York in pursuit of...
这一切是怎么开始的？你当时，这是一个目标吗？你出生在明尼阿波利斯，对吧。你拿到了新闻学学位，也许是吧？然后又拿了商业学位？对，那是次失败。我没读完。然后你前往纽约去追求……
Just not living in a small town.
Okay.
It was really a classic.
And it was kind of like a, like, let me go out east and, like, strike gold in the same way that, you know, there's a Silicon Valley rush and the gold rush.
And I was like, oh, I'm going to go to New York.
I'm going to get rich and famous.
And that was a long time.
That was 15 years ago.
只是为了不生活在小镇上。好吧。这真的很经典。而且它有点像那种，比如“让我去东部淘金吧”，就像硅谷热和淘金热一样。当时我就想，哦，我要去纽约。我要变得富有和出名。那是很久以前的事了。那是15年前的事了。
Any industry you had focused on or is just like that town has a lot of different ones.
We'll see what hits.
At the time, I was very much into, like, entrepreneurship in this, like,
The social network had just come out.
I was like, oh, like, that's like, that was cool.
Remember for a while that was really cool?
It was really cool to be like a tech founder.
Right, right.
你专注于哪个行业，还是说那个城市有很多不同的行业？我们看看哪个能成。当时我非常热衷于创业这类的东西，像《社交网络》刚刚上映。当时我就想，哦，这，这真的很酷。还记得有一段时间这真的很酷吗？成为一名科技创始人真的很酷？对，对。
And I was like, oh, that's the way you do it.
And all these young people were like making so much money.
And I was like, oh, I think I should be a tech guy.
Right.
Take technology, use your creativity, your insight, your savviness,
and see where the two could intersect.
Yeah.
But really the ultimate goal was to strike it rich.
当时我就想，哦，这就是你要走的路。所有这些年轻人都在赚大钱，我就想，哦，我想我应该成为一个搞科技的人。对。利用科技，发挥你的创造力、洞察力和精明，看看这两者能碰撞出什么火花。对。但真正的终极目标是发大财。
Yeah, it was definitely in pursuit of, yeah, yeah.
I was like, let's get to the...
And I did the opposite.
I did the exact opposite, because I got a job at Vice.
Yeah.
And Vice pays you, it's like they get three, they get a three-for-one deal,
so they get like three 25-year-old kids.
They pay you in cocaine.
对，绝对是为了追求，对，对。当时我就想，让我们直奔……结果我做了完全相反的事情。我做了极其相反的事，因为我在《Vice》杂志找到了一份工作。对。而且《Vice》付给你的薪水，就好像他们占了三倍便宜，他们雇佣三个25岁的年轻人。他们用可卡因付工资给你。
Is that what you're going to say?
They do.
They actually do.
At least holiday bonuses for paid and cut.
I remember Christmas, it was like, here's a bag of blow.
And I was like, oh, cool, this is so cool.
This is so interesting.
Sure.
你是想这么说吗？他们确实这么干。他们真的这么干。至少假期奖金是发可卡因的。我记得圣诞节的时候，他们说，这里有一包可卡因。当时我就想，哦，酷，这太酷了。这太有意思了。当然。
Could I pay my rent with Blow?
So your advice and you're doing marketing stuff with them, maybe, yeah?
Yeah, I'm doing like content development and marketing
and kind of like launching new shows.
And I was never the talent, but I wanted to be the talent.
Were you working with like Shane and Eddie and all those guys?
Yeah.
And at the time it was like 75 people, so we were all in the same room.
我可以用可卡因付房租吗？所以你在《Vice》工作，跟他们一起做市场营销之类的事情，也许是吧？对，我当时做的是内容开发、市场营销，有点像推出新节目。我从来都不是出镜的人，但我很想出镜。你当时跟沙恩（Shane）、埃迪（Eddie）以及所有那些人一起工作吗？对。当时公司只有大概75个人，所以我们都在同一个房间里。
Yeah.
And I was listening to them on the phone.
And I'm like, whoa, this is so cool.
Like, it really was, like, getting...
That was a real MBA in business
because I'm, like, sitting in this room
with Shane and Eddie and Sirouche and all these guys.
I'm, like, listening to them.
对。我当时听他们打电话。然后我就想，哇，这太酷了。真的就像是，得到了……那是一次真正的商业管理硕士（MBA）培训，因为我坐在那个房间里，和沙恩、埃迪、苏鲁什（Siroush）以及所有这些人在一块儿。我听着他们谈话。
Sirush, I love Sirush.
He's awesome.
He's such a good guy.
Like, I just saw him the other day.
He's the greatest guy.
He's so cool.
Well, from a marketing standpoint and also a content,
苏鲁什，我喜欢苏鲁什。他太棒了。他是个很好的人。我前几天还刚见过他。他是个极好的人。他太酷了。他太酷了。好吧，从市场营销和内容的角度来看，
that was such an exciting company
and hearing about it, seeing it coming,
and getting it.
on board and kind of following it
you guys did a great job at that.
It was really cool. It was really cool. And it felt
like we were doing something like it was like... And Spike
was around a bunch there too, wasn't he?
那真是一家令人兴奋的公司，听闻它的故事，看着它崛起，然后加入进去并一路跟随，你们在这方面做得太棒了。真的很酷。真的很酷。感觉我们当时在做一些事情，就像是……斯派克（Spike）当时也在那儿待了不少时间，对吧？
Yeah, he was like the
executive creative director, which meant that he just
got to say that.
And he would hang out.
Like, he was just like, that's such a cool job.
David Cross was kicking around a little bit too, wasn't it?
That was early days. He wasn't there at that point.
Yeah. No, I was there in 2012.
对，他当时是执行创意总监，这意味着他的工作就是说出那种头衔。而且他经常在那儿晃荡。就像，他就是这样，那真是一份酷毙了的工作。大卫·克罗斯（David Cross）当时也经常在那儿转悠，对吧？那是早期的时候。他那时候不在那儿。对。不，我是在2012年在那儿的。
Yeah.
And then, and from there you go to the New York Times?
Yes.
Yeah.
And for them, you did what?
Less Coke, I bet.
I did the same thing.
对。然后，从那里你去了《纽约时报》？是的。对。对。你在那里做了什么？我猜吸的白粉少多了。我干的还是同一件事。
A lot less Coke.
A lot, a lot less Coke.
It was kind of like, that's why I quit.
Of course.
The Times was like, we just pay money.
And I was like, mm.
Yeah, you're like, well.
Money can't buy Coke.
少得多的白粉。少得多，少得多的白粉。那正是我想辞职的原因。当然。《纽约时报》的态度是，我们只给钱。然后我就想，嗯。对，你就会想。钱买不到白粉。
It's Christmas, and I haven't seen my blow yet.
Did I not perform this year?
E-mailing the editor-in-chief.
I'm like, hey, dude, I'm going to quit unless I get, like, a little bonus here.
So what were you doing for, what did you do for New York Times?
I was doing the same thing.
I, like, helped start Times video, which now makes film and television and kind of the podcasting and all that stuff.
So I was, like, laying the groundwork for all that.
圣诞节到了，我还没见到我的可卡因。难道我今年表现得不够好吗？给总编辑发电子邮件。我就说，嘿，老兄，除非我能拿点小奖金，否则我要辞职了。那你当时在《纽约时报》做什么，你都做了些什么？我做的是同样的事。我帮忙创办了《纽约时报》视频部门，现在他们制作电影、电视、播客以及所有这些东西。所以，我是在为所有这些打下基础。
And it was really cool, but then I did.
So this is, like, I think I was, like, in New York for, like, maybe seven or eight years.
And at that point, I was like, okay, I know enough people.
I have enough information and knowledge and, like, maybe some access to money.
that I can actually go start my thing,
like my media company.
And that was a massive failure.
But I did do that for a couple of years.
这真的很酷，但后来我还是走了。所以，这大概是，我想我在纽约待了大概七、八年吧。到了那个时候，我在想，好吧，我认识的人够多了。我拥有足够的信息、知识，可能还有一些获取资金的渠道，这样我就可以真正出去开创自己的事业了，比如我的媒体公司。那是一次彻底的失败。不过我确实搞了几年。
What was that first swing and miss?
Well, there was like a couple in a row.
It was along at that.
Yeah, it was like, it was three strikes.
Those three strikes.
And then I was out.
And that's when I was like,
maybe I'm not so good at being like a CEO or an entrepreneur.
那次初次尝试碰壁是怎么回事？嗯，接连遭遇了好几次。差不多就是那样。对，就像是，那是三振出局。那三次全被三振了。然后我就出局了。也就是在那时我心想，也许我并不擅长当什么首席执行官或创业者。
And maybe I should just be, like, do what I'm good at,
which it seems like,
hanging out, like I'm really good at hanging out.
And, like, you know, podcastings, just really, you guys are just hang out guys.
Yeah, just interviewing, having conversations.
We're hanging out, kids, for sure.
Yeah, so I was like, maybe I should try my hand to that.
But the first swing and a mess was something called NYC.tv.
也许我应该只做我擅长的事，看起来好像是，到处闲逛，因为我真的很擅长闲逛。而且，你知道，播客，其实就是，你们就是一群喜欢闲逛的人。对，就是采访，聊天。我们就是爱闲逛的小伙子，肯定的。对，所以我就想，也许我应该去尝试一下这个。但第一次初次尝试碰壁是一个叫 NYC.tv 的东西。
And the idea was to do public access television on the internet.
Right.
Which I was like, that's a clever little something, something, something.
Yeah.
And it just didn't work.
And then I shifted that into something called Nameless Network, which was like,
do you remember like now this news
like these
当时的想法是在互联网上做公共电视节目。没错。当时我还觉得，这真是一个聪明的小东西，小玩意儿，小把戏。对。但它就是行不通。后来我把它转型成了一个叫 Nameless Network 的东西，就像是，你还记得像 NowThis News 这种新闻吗？
they're kind of like made like
thousands of viral videos every month
that would be like
this guy is selling yams in Japan
on a street corner dressed as a cat
you never saw like videos
no
they were like short like two minute videos
它们有点像是，每个月制作成千上万个病毒式传播的视频，内容大概是：这个人在日本的街角打扮成猫在卖山药。你从来没见过这种视频，不，它们是很短的视频，大概两分钟。
and it would just be like big text on a screen
and it would be like this school
in Turkey is offering free
haircuts to young people
so just like I mean real attention
Like, grabbers.
Yeah.
I mean, stuff that's really mattering to people.
屏幕上会有大大的文字，内容会是：土耳其的这所学校为年轻人提供免费理发服务。所以就像是——我的意思是，真正的注意力抓取器。我的意思是，那些对人们真正重要的事情。
Yams in Japan, haircuts in Turkey.
I mean, and you're telling me that this did not take off.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
So then a few swings and misses.
And then you say, well, maybe I should just grab a camera and a microphone, get in front of it.
And start doing what comes natural, which is just kind of being a man of the people.
and see what comes.
日本的山药，土耳其的理发。我的意思是，你告诉我这居然没有火起来。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。经历了几次碰壁之后。然后你说，好吧，也许我应该拿起相机和麦克风，走到镜头前。开始做那些顺理成章的事，也就是当一个平民代言人，看看会发生什么。
So what was that first thing
that kind of grabbed
and you could feel the momentum moving
and this may be working.
The first big hill was a show
that I created.
And this is a time when there was like no shows.
Like there was no short form
那么，最初是哪件事吸引了大家的注意，让你能感觉到势头正在形成，而且这事可能行得通？第一个大热门是我创作的一个节目。那是一个根本没有什么节目的时代。当时没有短视频。
unscripted vertical video shows.
And I say that.
And it was just like everyone was making content,
but there was no like show in this thing.
But I decided to make a show
and I was like, why isn't there just a TV show?
that's distributed on TikTok and Instagram,
and it was called Keep the Meter Running.
无剧本的竖屏视频节目。我这么说是为了说明。当时每个人都在创作内容，但并没有像样的节目。但我决定制作一个节目，当时我在想，为什么没有一个纯粹的电视节目？是在 TikTok 和 Instagram 上分发的，它叫《让计价器一直走》（Keep the Meter Running）。
And it was this concept where I would hail a cab
and just tell the driver to take me wherever they want.
And it was always insane.
Like it would just be so crazy.
Like one time I hail the cab.
The taxi driver has it flipped on him or her
where they're not being told where to go by the person in the back,
but you get to take me, the passenger,
这个概念是这样的：我会拦下一辆出租车，然后告诉司机把我带到他们想去的任何地方。而且过程总是疯狂至极。简直疯狂得不行。比如有一次我拦下一辆出租车。出租车司机的角色反过来了，不是坐在后座的人告诉他们去哪儿，而是你可以把我——这个乘客，
wherever you driver, want to go.
And just keep the meter running and tell me about why you like that.
this place. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I would just go take me
your favorite place and keep the meter running. And
I would end up, like, one time I ended
up, like, in New Jersey
on a helicopter with this guy from Morocco. And he was
literally just
带到你——司机，想去的任何地方。只要让计价器一直走，然后告诉我你为什么喜欢这个地方。对，对，对。我就会说，带我去你最喜欢的地方，让计价器一直走。结果我最后，比如有一次我最后竟然和这个来自摩洛哥的家伙一起坐上了新泽西的一架直升机。他字面意义上就是
getting and driving. No way. Can you drive it?
Really? Wow. But yeah, he had
a pint of Malibu, which I thought was an interesting
choice. That is an interesting choice. That is an interesting. Right, right.
It was nice. The white bottle. It's smooth.
Sure.
So you do that. So you do the keep the meter running
for a while.
上车然后开着。没门。你会开吗？真的吗？哇。不过是的，他有一品脱马里布朗姆酒（Malibu），我觉得这是一个很有趣的选择。那确实是一个有趣的选择。那真是一个有趣的。对，对。挺不错的。白色的瓶子。口感很顺滑。当然。所以你做了这个。所以你做了一段时间的《让计价器一直走》。
Yeah, I do like 20 episodes.
And still going.
Yes, and now it's back.
The meter, well, I had to stop
because at the time it was my first thing and I was a massive failure,
remember, and I had no money.
And those episodes were, obviously,
when you tell a guy, keep the meter running and he goes,
对，我大概拍了20集。而且现在还在继续。是的，现在它回归了。计价器，好吧，我当时不得不停下来，因为在当时那是我的第一个项目，而且我记得我曾经惨败过，我根本没有钱。那些剧集很显然，当你对一个司机说“让计价器一直走”，然后他回答说：
let's go on a helicopter ride in New Jersey,
by the end of the day, you spent literally $2,000.
Sure, right, yeah, yeah, right.
And so I could only do, I spent all of my money.
Oh, my God.
And then I was like, I have to put this on pause.
And then I was like, and now it's back.
except bigger.
“我们去新泽西坐直升机兜风吧”，到了那天结束的时候，你literally花掉了2000美元。当然，没错，对，对，对。所以我也只能做，我花光了所有的钱。天哪。然后我就想：我必须得暂停这个项目了。再后来我就想：它现在又回来了。而且规模更大了。
Now it's like YouTube,
it's like 20-minute episodes.
Sure, right.
It's crazy now.
I'm so surprised,
how do you get them to,
because I know a lot of cab drivers
that I want to,
现在就像是 YouTube 上的那种20分钟长的节目。当然，对。现在太疯狂了。我很惊讶，你是怎么让他们，因为我认识很多出租车司机，我想……
the cabs I get in.
Oh, do you, Sean?
You know a lot of cab drivers.
They don't, no, they don't want to talk.
What?
Yeah, they don't want to.
Guys, have you experienced that?
我坐的出租车。哦，是吗，肖恩？你认识很多出租车司机。他们不，不，他们不想说话。什么？对，他们不想。什么？伙计们，你们经历过吗？
They all want to talk.
Just not to Sean.
Oh, all right.
No.
Well, maybe I don't.
Maybe I don't talk.
They're usually on the phone,
and they want to just keep their conversation
他们都想聊天。只是不想跟肖恩聊。哦，好吧。不，也许我不会。也许我不怎么说话。他们通常都在打电话，只想继续他们在电话里的对话。我只是以为他们不想聊天。哦，你不能让他们闭嘴。特别是当你架起摄像机的时候，对吧？他们会挂断电话，对。也许只是挑起话头，比如，直接说。那，你知道的，比如政治？出租车牌照。
going on their phone.
I just assume they don't want to chat.
Oh, you can't tell them to stop talking.
Especially when you get the camera going, right?
They hang up, yeah.
Maybe just bring up, like, just be like so.
How about, you know, like politics?
Medallians.
别提车牌照。不，我只是觉得那是个真正的热门话题。那么，人们开始观看《让计价器一直走》的第一个迹象是什么？你是怎么发现的？老实说，就是第二天。所以，我发布了视频，然后把手机关机了，因为我想，这又是一个失败的项目。当时我已经习惯了不断的失败。
Don't bring up medallions.
No, I just figured that that's a real hot topic.
So what was the first sign that people were watching Keep the Meter running?
How did you find out?
Legitimately the next day.
So, like, I posted the video and I turned my phone off
because I was, like, another failure.
I was conditioned to just fail at that point.
当你说的发布时，你是把它发到哪个平台上了？我把它发到了 TikTok 和 Instagram 上。好的。当时你已经有一些粉丝了。但不多，大概3万左右吧，你知道的？所以粉丝多到足以，你知道的。让他们把视频转发给他们身边的人。病毒式传播就是这样发生的，对吧？
When you say post it, what did you throw it up on?
I put it on TikTok and Instagram.
Okay.
Of which you had already some followers.
But not a lot, like 30,000, you know?
And so enough to like, you know.
For them to then send it out to their folks.
And that's how viral happens, right?
哦，等一下。给我们讲讲这个过程，JB 爷爷简直是……我等不及要听你对这背后的运作原理的理解了……难道这不是一种指数级的传播吗？我注意到你刚才没在里面说“算法”这个词。你实际上说的是朋友们。我把那个词留到后面说。
Oh, hang on a second.
Walk us through that, J.B.
Granddad is just...
I can't wait to hear your understanding of how this is...
Isn't it an exponential dissemination of...
I noticed you didn't say the word algorithm in that.
You actually said that the friends.
I say that for later.
哦，对。那是他的压轴大招。这个主意太棒了。所以你把它发上去，然后关掉手机，当天晚些时候你打开手机，然后……嗯，第二天早上我去小卖部。那时候，我刚重新打开手机，但我没有登录。
Oh, yeah.
That's his closer.
It's such a great idea.
So you put it up and you turn off your phone,
you turn on your phone later that night and...
Well, I go to the bodega the next morning.
And at this point, I just turned my phone back on,
but I didn't log.
就像我没有打开那些应用。我走到小卖部，那家伙说：“哦，你看起来好面熟。”我说：“不知道，我就是个失败者。我来过这儿上百万次了。”就像，我真的经常来这儿。我看起来面熟是因为你每天都能见到我。对。
like I didn't open the apps.
I went to the bodega and the guy goes,
oh, you look so familiar.
And I go, I don't know, I'm a loser.
I've been here a million times.
Like, I've literally been here.
I look familiar because I see you every day.
Right.
然后他说：“不，你看起来真的好面熟。”接着他说：“出租车，你就是那个出租车小哥。你拍了那个节目。”当时我就想：什么？我打开手机一看，已经有大概两百万的播放量了。不，哇。在一夜之间。
And he goes, no, you look so familiar.
And then he goes,
taxi, you're the taxi guy.
You did the show.
And I was like, what?
And I opened my phone and it has like two million views.
No, wow.
In a night.
对。还有那么多，成千上万条评论。当时我就想：卧槽，这居然真的成功了。那种感觉就像是，我做了一件有史以来头一次人们做出回应的事，而且它正做着我以为自己能做好的事情——也就是闲逛。
Yeah.
And so many, like, thousands of comments.
And I was like, holy shit, it actually worked.
And it felt like that moment where I was like,
I did something that for the first time ever,
people responded to it,
and it was doing exactly what I thought I could do well,
which is hang out.
当时我就想：天哪，也许我终于找到属于我的方向了。对。你知道的，我给我妈打电话。我说：我知道我以后要靠什么维生了。我就是要跟其他人一起闲逛。所以你立刻尝试加倍下注、三倍下注，推出下一集。
And I was like, oh my God,
like maybe I'm finally found my thing.
Yeah.
You know, I called my mom.
I was like, I know what I'm going to do for a living.
I'm just going to hang out with other people.
And so you immediately tried to double down,
triple down, have another episode.
那天早上先买了一辆法拉利。那天早上买了一辆法拉利。这事肯定能成。新一季节目即将首播。是19号，对吧？5月13号，不管那天是几号。5月13号，是的。我想那是，我想今天是11号。
Bought a Ferrari first.
About a Ferrari that morning.
This is going to pan out.
The new episode, the new season is premiering soon.
It's the 19th, right?
May 13th, whatever that is.
May 13th, yes.
I think that's in, I think this is the 11th today.
我想两天后就是了。那是第几季？这大概是我做电视节目的核心理念的第一部官方正片，并且把它放到了 YouTube 上。但是，这并不是一个 YouTube 节目，因为它是电视制作级别的制作，拥有电视级别的叙事。
I think it's in two days.
So what season is that?
This is like the first official season of my,
I'm bringing my thesis of making television.
and putting it on YouTube.
But, like, it's not a YouTube show
because it is television quality production
and television storytelling.
而且，我们有……你知道的，我去了俄罗斯-土耳其浴场，和一个叫叶夫根尼（Eugene）的家伙以及他的朋友鲍里斯一起。他当时在打电话。我们稍后再聊这个。我们先聊聊节目。这就是那个节目！哦，哦，抱歉。
And, like, we have...
You know, I went to, like, the Russian Turkic bathhouse
with a guy named Eugene and his friend Boris.
He was on the phone.
We'll get into that later.
Let's talk about the show.
That is the show!
Oh, oh, sorry.
还有，你知道的，做那个。我制作了一部戏剧，主角是一个叫爱尔兰约翰（Irish John）的爱尔兰出租车司机。那不是他的真名，但，你知道的，我都这么叫他。然后他说：“我有一个单人脱口秀节目。”我说：“这到底是讲什么的？”
And, you know, do that.
I'm producing...
I produced a play for an Irish cab driver
named Irish John.
That's not his name.
but, you know, I call him that.
And he goes, I have a one-man show, and I go,
what's this all about?
于是他把我带到他的地下室，给我看了这个单人秀。我说：“太酷了，我们把它搬上剧院吧。”所以，你知道的，在300人面前表演，全都是自己制作的，看起来就像是一场单口喜剧专场，而且，你知道的，去熊山和一名叫扬（Young）的韩国人一起钓鱼画画。这真的非常了不起。整部节目的核心贯穿线其实是：如何做一个更好的男人。
So he takes me to his basement, he shows me this one-man show.
I go, cool, let's put it in a theater.
So, you know, performing in front of 300 people,
all self-produced, looks like a stand-up special,
and, you know, go fishing with a Korean guy named Young in Bear Mountain and sketch.
And just, it's really remarkable.
And the whole kind of through line of the show is, like,
how to be a better man.
比如如何做一个更好的兄弟，如何做一个更好的父亲，如何做一个更好的朋友。这一切都是因为这些家伙掌握着宇宙的秘密。你知道的，就像你每天开车12个小时，生活很艰难，
Like how to be a better brother,
how to be a better father,
how to be a better friend.
It's all,
because these guys have like
the secret to the universe.
You know, like you're driving for 12 hours a day,
your life is hard,
你要把钱寄回家，或者你只是在养家糊口，他们身上有一种父辈般的智慧。我不知道你们当中有没有人很早就失去了父亲。我20岁时失去了父亲。我开始和这些出租车司机进行这些对话，因为我觉得他们有一些建议。
you're sending money home,
or you're just supporting your family,
and they like have this fatherly wisdom.
I don't know if any of you guys lost your father early.
I lost mine when I was 20.
And I started like having these convos
with these cab drivers
because I felt like they had some advice.
可以给我。对。你知道的，我当时还没有威尔的电话号码，所以我不能打电话给他。我没办法向他寻求建议。肖恩没有失去父亲。
for me.
Right.
You know,
and I didn't have
Will's number yet,
so I couldn't call him.
I couldn't call him for advice.
Sean didn't lose his dad.
他父亲走丢了。对，哇，这真的很了不起，老兄。太酷了。对，这真的很酷。然后接下来，给我们讲讲，后来地铁访谈（Subway Takes）是怎么诞生的？你有了这个想法，
His dad got lost.
Yeah.
So, wow, that's really remarkable, man.
That's so cool.
Yeah, that's really cool.
And then so then tell us about,
then subway takes happens.
You feel, you get an idea for that
并且觉得你可以同时进行？嗯，我当时钱已经花光了，因为另一个节目每集的成本高达2000美元。所以当时我在想，好吧，这种短视频无剧本的形式对我来说真的挺管用的。还有什么类似的版本，但成本更低呢？而且，就像……抱歉，我打断你一下。
and you figure you can do it at the same time simultaneously?
Well, I had.
run out of the money because the other show was costing like $2,000 per episode.
And so I was like, okay, this is this whole like short form unscripted thing is like really
working for me.
What's like another version of that which is less expensive?
And again, like...
Sorry, let me just stop you for one second.
教教我和我们的听众，因为这可能非常吸引人。对我来说绝对是的。拍那个节目怎么会把钱花光呢？因为我想问题是，你怎么通过那种节目来赚钱呢？你把它发到 Instagram 和 TikTok 上。你怎么会觉得那种东西能赚钱呢？创作者怎么能通过那个赚钱呢？你能在那类短视频里做广告吗？对，就像那个家伙看到的，他看到了你的第一集。一夜之间有了两00万的播放量。你实时看到真金白银进账了吗？不，我看到的零美元。
Educate me and our listener because this might be fascinating.
It certainly would be to me.
How do you run out of money doing that show?
Because I guess the question is, how do you monetize a show?
show like that. So you put it up on Instagram and TikTok. How are you even thinking you could get
paid for that? How does a creator get paid for that? Can you advertise against those little short form?
Yeah, like the guy made you see, he sees your first episode. It's got two million views overnight.
Are you seeing that in real time in dollars coming to you? No, I'm seeing zero dollars.
这就是问题所在。这就是我的问题。你怎么会指望通过那个赚钱呢？你怎么能从中获得报酬呢？你会希望，比如有一个品牌本质上来说：我喜欢你在做的事。嘿，你愿不愿意每集都用你的大通（Chase）借记卡或信用卡来支付出租车司机的车费？或者你愿不愿意完全通过 WhatsApp 与他们的家人和你的朋友进行沟通，巴拉巴拉？
That's the problem. That's my question. How would you even hope to monetize that? How would you get paid for that?
You would want, like, a brand to essentially say,
I love what you're doing.
Hey, do you want to pay in every episode,
do you want to use your Chase debit card or credit card
to pay for the cabbies bill?
Or do you want to communicate using WhatsApp exclusively
with, like, their families and your friends, and blah, blah?
这就是问题所在。这也是我的问题。你怎么能指望从那个中获利呢？你怎么能为此获得报酬呢？你会希望，比如，有一个品牌基本上会说，我喜欢你正在做的事。嘿，你想在每一集里付费吗，你想用你的大通借记卡或信用卡来支付出租车司机的账单吗？或者你想专门通过WhatsApp与他们的家人和你的朋友之类的人进行交流，等等？
So you'd want someone to underwrite the series.
In the same way that, like, a streamer or a production company
or a network would underwrite, it's brand-funded entertainment.
So you were pursuing that and getting no bites?
So you just didn't know to do that yet.
I didn't know to do that yet.
And I also was, like, so overwhelmed and just kind of, I was in panic mode.
Like, I don't know what to do with this.
所以你会希望有人来赞助这个系列。就像流媒体、制作公司或电视台会赞助的那样，这是品牌资助的娱乐节目。所以你当时在寻求这种赞助，但没有得到任何回应？所以你当时还不知道该怎么做。我当时确实不知道。而且我也感到非常不知所措，处于恐慌状态。心想，我不知道该拿这个怎么办。
You know, I don't.
And actually, the first thing I did was like, I was like, okay, maybe this should be a TV show instead.
And, like, I should get money from someone in Hollywood.
Right.
And, but that whole rigamarole.
Yeah.
I went on, like, a wild goose chase with that.
I was like, I don't know.
你知道的，我确实不知道。实际上，我做的第一件事是，我觉得，好吧，也许这应该改成一个电视节目。然后，你知道的，我应该从好莱坞的某个人那里拿到资金。对吧。但是那一整套繁文缛节。是的，我为那事进行了一场徒劳的追逐。我当时想，我不知道。
This is, yeah, it was taking too long.
And in the meantime, I was like, let me start another thing.
while this is baking in the TV world,
let me start another thing to kind of like continue my work.
But what made you think that second thing
would be something that you would be able to monetize
and get money out of?
I didn't really think about that either.
这，是的，花的时间太长了。与此同时，我想，不如我再开始做别的事情吧。当这个项目在电视界酝酿的同时，让我开始做点别的事情，好让我的工作继续下去。但你为什么会觉得这第二件事是你能够将其商业化并从中赚钱的呢？我当时其实也没怎么考虑过这个问题。
It was really more so like, like this is making.
I'm really noticing a trend here.
Yeah.
You thought, I'm not making any money with the thing.
This thing's costing me money.
What I should do is interview Jason Bateman on the subway,
holding a metric card instead of a microphone.
That'll do it.
它其实更像是，就像这个正在制作中。我真的注意到这里有一个趋势。是的。你当时想，我从那件事上赚不到钱。这件事还在让我花钱。我应该做的是在地铁上采访杰森·贝特曼，手里拿一张大都会卡，而不是麦克风。那样就行了。
It worked.
I'm here.
It did.
I loved J.B.
I loved your episode.
I thought you were going on.
Oh, man, I did too.
What a fun time I had that.
这招管用。我这不就来了。确实管用。我很喜欢杰森·贝特曼。我很喜欢你的那一集。我还以为你要继续说呢。哦，天哪，我也这么觉得。我当时过得真开心。
If you guys have not seen Subway Takes,
and I haven't seen Keep the Meter running yet.
I can't wait to watch that.
I know me too.
Oh, I need both of you guys on there.
Tell people what Subway Takes what the concept of that is.
So Subway Takes is essentially like a two-minute talk show on the train
where I interview like local stand-up comedians,
如果你们还没看过《地铁观点》（Subway Takes），而且我还没看过《让仪表盘运转》（Keep the Meter Running）。我等不及要看了。我知道，我也是。哦，我需要你们两个都上那个节目。给大家讲讲《地铁观点》这个节目的概念是什么。所以《地铁观点》基本上就像是在地铁上的两分钟脱口秀，我在车上采访一些当地的单口喜剧演员，
regular comedians, musicians, writers, directors,
like anyone who I find kind of interesting
and also people like Jason Bateman.
Right, so then you, and then you had Jason on.
Yeah, we got to balance it out.
It must have...
You can't appreciate the big ones
unless you get a couple of clunkers.
常规喜剧演员、音乐人、作家、导演，任何我觉得有点意思的人，还有像杰森·贝特曼这样的人。对吧，然后你，然后你邀请了杰森。是的，我们得把嘉宾阵容平衡一下。这一定……你得请几个表现一般的，才能衬托出大腕的精彩。
I found him kind of interesting.
I was just like he's kind of interesting.
You know what I mean?
It's an interesting.
I'm curious about the details of your episode with J.B.
Well, okay, concept,
But I really want to know what station did you guys get in?
Yeah, what did you guys do?
我觉得他挺有意思的。我当时就觉得他挺有意思的。你知道我的意思吗？这是一个有趣的。我对你和杰森那一集的细节很好奇。好吧，概念是这样的，但我真的很想知道你们是在哪个车站上车的？是的，你们都做了什么？
What train were you on and where did you get?
We were lower east side.
Yes, we were in Chinatown on the F train at East Broadway.
Wow.
Yes, I remember.
I had to boil my entire body after that.
And Jason, I mean, what was, Jason, the look on your driver's face when you said, take me there.
He said, let you out here.
你们坐的是哪趟车，在哪儿上的？我们在下东区。是的，我们在唐人街的F线东百老汇站。哇。是的，我记得。在那之后，我得把全身都煮沸消毒一下。杰森，我是说，当时情况是怎样的，杰森，当你对司机说，带我去那儿时，你司机的表情是怎样的。他说，把你放在这儿？
I said, no, no, no, hang on.
Just keep the door close for a minute.
Jason brought an extra pair of pants.
hands and an extra shirt.
And some plastic to sit on.
He called it his train clothes.
That's what he called his train clothes.
And he was wearing white latex gloves.
我说，不不不，等一下。先把门关上一分钟。杰森带了一条备用裤子和一件备用衬衫。还有一块用来坐的塑料垫。他管这叫他的“地铁服装”。他就是这么叫他的“地铁服装”的。而且他还戴着白色乳胶手套。
And I was like, why are you wearing those?
That sounds right.
I love the train.
I'm in the Metro card.
So you go, you decide, all right.
But the concept is, listener, is that he has somebody come on and just give one hot take on something.
Right.
And Kareem decides whether he's 100.
然后我就问：“你为什么戴着那些？”听起来很合情合理。我喜欢地铁。我有大都会卡。所以你决定，好吧。但这个概念是，听众朋友们，就是他找一个人来，对某事发表一个激进的观点。对吧。然后卡里姆（Kareem）来决定他是100%赞成还是反对。
percent on board with that or in opposition to that.
For instance, my dumbass hot take was I think all dogs should wear shoes.
100% agree.
But then the interview is, well, why do you agree and why do I think they're doing it?
Basically, you know, I just think, you know, so that they, you know, you don't want them to walk into your place and track in all the poo they like to walk around in.
Yeah.
So anyway.
But so that's kind of the concept.
百分之百赞成。但接下来的采访是，嗯，为什么你赞成，为什么我认为他们在这么做？基本上，你知道的，我只是觉得，你知道的，这样他们，你知道的，你不会希望他们走到你家里，把他们喜欢到处踩的便便都带进来。对吧。所以不管怎样。但这就是这个节目的概念。
and it's a two-minute concept
and it's pleasurable
and we're popping around the city
and...
You think dogs, if dogs go to a play
they should go backstage.
And see the artists.
Sorry, we'll go to that later.
这是一个两分钟的概念，很有趣，我们在城市里到处穿梭……你觉得狗狗们，如果狗狗去看戏剧，它们应该去后台。去见见艺术家们。抱歉，我们待会儿再聊这个。
But Kareem, can we do a hot take to you?
Like, because I just thought of this
when you popped on about that show
and I was like, doing Broadway shows,
you know those rickshaws
that are super fucking loud?
Yeah.
At night?
但是卡里姆，我们能向你抛出一个激进的观点吗？因为当你在节目里谈到这个时我突然想到了，比如在百老汇演出，你知道那些超级他妈吵的人力车吗？对吧。在晚上？
Yeah, yeah.
Like, shouldn't there be a law against the sound of those?
100% agree.
Yeah, there's too much noise pollution in New York City.
Oh, Sean, is this our segment called Old Man Gripes?
What are we doing?
对，对。比如，难道不应该有一条法律来管管那些噪音吗？百分之百赞成。百分之百赞成。是的，纽约市的噪音污染太严重了。哦，肖恩，这是我们的那个叫“老头抱怨”的环节吗？我们在干什么？我们在干什么？
Yeah.
And shouldn't those damn kids slow down in the neighborhood?
No, he's right.
It's too damn loud.
I agree.
You're so synonymous with New York.
I just thought, you know, what do you think about?
Like, because I don't have any skin in the game with Mom Dani.
对啊。难道那些该死的小屁孩不应该在社区里放慢车速吗？不，他是对的。声音太他妈大了。我同意。你简直成了纽约的代名词。我只是在想，你觉得怎么样？因为我对曼达尼（Mom Dani）没有什么利害关系。
I don't know if he's good or bad or anything.
I don't live, you know, I'm just here part-time working.
But somebody complained that it's because of Mom Dane
that the snow banks weren't clear.
I'm like, the snow.
When there's a blizzard, there's never, you can't clear all the snow.
Yeah, where do you want them to put it?
Yeah.
我不知道他是好是坏，还是别的什么。我不住在那儿，你知道的，我只是来这里兼职工作。但有人抱怨说，正是因为曼达尼，雪堆才没有被清理干净。我说，这雪。当暴风雪来临时，根本不可能，你不可能清理掉所有的雪。对吧，你希望他们把雪堆到哪里去？对吧。
Well, you got to, being the mayor of New York is the worst job in America.
Yeah.
Because everyone's just mad at you no matter what you do.
Right, for sure.
For sure.
It's a historical, big L.
I would never do it, although I might.
Have you ever had somebody that...
好吧，你得承认，当纽约市长是美国最糟糕的工作。对吧。因为无论你做什么，每个人都在生你的气。对，肯定的。肯定的。这是一项历史性的巨大烂摊子。我绝不会去干，虽然我也许会。你有没有遇到过这样的人……
Uh-oh.
Have you ever had somebody...
Talk about breaking fucking...
I would only do it as a joke,
and then I would accidentally win, like, you know who, our boy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, whoopsies, I'm the mirror now.
Just trying to sell a book.
噢，不。你有没有遇到过这样的人……谈到打破他妈的……我只有在开玩笑的时候才会去干，然后我会不小心赢得选举，就像你知道的那样，我们的好哥们。对，对，对。比如，哎呀，我现在是市长了。我本来只是想卖本书。
What, has anybody come on and not had a take,
and then you had to say, all right, well, I'll do one.
Well, didn't you go through the vetting process, Jason?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, I was given a heads up, but, you know, I'm a professional.
I can't prepare.
Sure, see if I can pull up some of it.
if some of these people come on and just like,
怎么，有没有人来上节目却没有什么观点，然后你不得不说，好吧，那我自己来一个？好吧，杰森，你不是经历过筛选流程吗？对的。对，对，我事先得到了通知，但是，你知道的，我是个专业人士。我不用做准备。当然，看看我能不能找出其中的一些片段。如果这些人上节目只是说，
yeah, I couldn't think of anything.
Should I see if Jason Bateman had any other ones
that we didn't use? Yeah.
Oh, did I pitch you some?
I don't know. Let me check my email.
So they go to someone on my team.
Yeah.
And then I don't, there's like somebody approves
对啊，我想不出什么来。我看看杰森·贝特曼有没有其他我们没用过的观点？噢，我有向你推销过一些吗？我不知道。我得查查我的电子邮件。所以他们会联系我团队里的某个人。对。然后我不会，会有某个人批准
that they're good.
Right.
And then, and then.
Like just some Gen Z kid?
Yeah, pretty literally.
Literally a young, young lads.
Which, what's the last one you disagreed with?
Oh, dude, I don't know.
说这些观点不错。对，然后，然后。就像某个Gen Z（Z世代）的小屁孩？对，差不多字面意思。字面意义上的年轻小伙子。话说，你最近反对的最后一个观点是什么？哦，老兄，我不知道。
I don't know.
You're doing one, what are you doing?
One a week?
No, we post one a day.
No.
What?
I post one a day.
Yeah, it's my soul.
我不知道。你现在在做一个，你到底在做几个？一周做一个吗？不，我们一天发一个。不对。什么？我一天发一个。对，这就是我的精神支柱。
So then you're doing one a day to keep up with the output?
No, I batch, I shoot, I'll shoot like 10 in one day.
No way.
It's really a miserable day.
I'm like a real working, you know, blue-collar guy.
I'm underground all day.
I'm sweating, or it's too cold, or it's too hot,
or the train's not working, or somebody's trying to stab me,
所以为了跟上产量，你一天得做一个？不，我批量制作，我拍摄，我一天能拍10个。开玩笑吧。那真是痛苦的一天。我简直就像是个真正的打工人，你知道的，蓝领阶层。我整天都在地下。我在流汗，要么太冷，要么太热，要么地铁坏了，要么有人想拿刀捅我，
from walker.
Yeah, it's really tough.
Don't you find that,
am I just an introvert?
A little lunch pal guy over here.
Am I just an introvert that needs to refill my talk tank a lot?
Or does everybody go through sort of like a social exhaustion like me sometimes?
Like, how do you not run out of being, you know, chatty?
从沃克街过来。对，这真的很艰难。你不觉得，难道我只是个内向的人吗？我这个小午餐盒男孩。难道我只是个需要经常补充社交能量的内向者吗？还是说每个人有时都会像我一样经历某种社交疲惫？比如，你怎么能做到一直滔滔不绝呢？
By doing 10 episodes in a day, how do you keep it going like that?
Will's raising us out.
Well, I've got a thought on this, which is,
Which is always, you know, when you go and you do interviews and stuff
doing what we do and you have to go on talk shows.
And when I realize that I don't have stuff to talk about it's because I haven't been out in the world.
And so a lot of people we know, including us or whatever,
spend these times in this world.
通过一天拍10集节目，你是怎么坚持下来的？威尔把我们带出来了。好吧，我对此有个想法，那就是，那就是每当你们去做采访之类的事情，做我们这一行必须去上脱口秀节目的时候。每当我意识到自己没什么可聊的，那是因为我没有去接触外面的世界。所以我们认识的很多人，包括我们自己在内，都在这个世界里度过这些时光。
And we're not out in bubbles and you're not engaged in a real way.
And about 50 years ago.
I would say, like, I want to experience life.
And that's why I'm always on the move and doing, I swear to God.
I know how boring that's a piece.
break so you're out there walking around with your
fucking hands tucked in your pockets
just like squinting around
我们不是生活在泡泡里，你也没有真正地融入其中。大约50年前。我会说，比如，我想体验生活。这就是为什么我一直在行动，一直在做事，我向上帝发誓。我知道这听起来多无聊，break，所以你就在外面走来走去，双手插在口袋里，眯着眼睛四处张望，
one hand how have a fucking
just soaking it all in hey good morning
man how you doing have a good day
no I'm serious
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
I'm more down to earth
or anything what I'm saying is that I realize
you have to get out there
一只手，怎么能他妈的就把这一切都吸收进去呢？嘿，早啊，老兄，最近怎么样，祝你过个好头？不，我是认真的。我不是说这个，我不是说我更脚踏实地什么的。我想说的是，我意识到你必须走出去。
Sean and I have talked about this
a number of times
and Jason you're a lost cause because you're at home or in the golf
course and so like that's okay
How the fuck would you have anything to talk about?
I could fill you in on what MS Now's new programming strategies are.
No, but it is true.
I think that there is something to that, right?
肖恩和我已经讨论过很多次了，杰森，你已经无药可救了，因为你总是待在家里或者在高尔夫球场上，所以这就——没关系。你他妈怎么可能会有任何谈资？我可以向你通报MS Now最新的节目策略是什么。不，但这是真的。我觉得这确实有一定道理，对吧？
Just being engaged.
I don't care who you are, just being engaged in the world.
Having stuff to say.
I get it.
Yeah.
Is that true?
Karim, is that your fuel?
就是去接触世界。我不管你是谁，就是要融入这个世界。得有话可说。我懂。对。对。是真的吗？卡里姆，这就是你的动力源泉吗？
No, I mean, I'm having fun.
Like, I really am having a lot of fun.
I have such a fun job.
Both of my jobs.
You're great at it.
hanging out with cab drivers, hanging out with people like you guys.
Like, it is the, I'm blessed as a person.
Like, I have the best job in the world.
不，我是说，我很开心。真的，我真的玩得很开心。我有一份非常有趣的工作。我的两份工作都是。你干得太棒了。跟出租车司机闲逛，跟你们这样的人闲逛。就像是，我是个有福气的人。我有世界上最好的工作。
And everything that I've done thus far has been totally independent.
So I really have no notes.
I have no development.
I'm just doing the fun part of the job, which is the making of it.
And that's all I do.
And it's really amazing.
And I have a lot of energy.
That's how we feel.
而且我迄今为止所做的一切都完全是独立的。所以我真的没有什么修改意见。我不需要经历开发阶段。我只是在做这份工作中最有趣的部分，那就是创作本身。这就是我所做的一切。这真的很神奇。我有很多精力。我们也是这么觉得的。
Amen.
What would five years from now look like if it continued on this,
on this angle of success.
What is your, what's your, what's your hope for where things go with this?
Like, well, go ahead.
I really don't know.
I mean, I'm kind of just playing about here.
Oriette Express.
阿门。如果以这种成功势头继续下去，五年后的情景会是什么样？你对事情的发展有什么期望？比如，请说吧。我真的不知道。我的意思是，我只是在瞎混。东方快车。
Just upgrading the train line.
Or gondolas, yachts, you know, Leo DiCaprio's yacht,
I could just have a permanent spot on there.
That would be pretty good.
That could be fun.
You just talked to him for 10 episodes.
Yeah.
I could.
只是升级一下地铁线路。或者缆车、游艇，你知道的，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥的游艇，我可以在上面占个永久的位子。那挺不错的。那一定很有趣。你刚才跟他聊了10集。对。我可以。
Yeah, that would be good.
Well, no, I talk to his wonderful guests.
I'm sure you guys have been on his yacht.
I'm not.
But like...
But I imagine, yeah, kind of going to, Jay, what you were saying,
which is like you do have...
I love that you did identify.
对，那会很棒。哦不，我跟他的那些优秀的嘉宾聊天。我确信你们俩都去过他的游艇。我没有。但是——但我可以想象，是的，有点像杰.杰森你刚才说的，也就是你确实有——我很高兴你确实识别出来了。
What you term as hanging out is actually engaging with people and talking...
Yes, and being curious.
And that's what you're good at and you're curious.
And you do have a point of view on a lot of stuff,
which is great and interesting.
And so I guess the next...
The evolution of that is...
taking that and going
你所谓的闲逛实际上是与人交往和交谈……是的，并且保持好奇心。这就是你擅长的，你很好奇。你对很多事情都有自己的观点，这很好也很酷。所以我想接下来的……这方面的演变就是……吸收这些并去——
and you talk to cab drivers and doing
the thing, take me where you want to go, and then talking to people
in the subway, and then would it be
kind of going broader, going around the world,
engaging with people in different
cultures? I mean, I imagine
you'd be really good at that. Exposing all of us
to other parts of the world and other
你去跟出租车司机交谈，做那个“带我去你想去的地方”的项目，然后在地铁里跟人交流，接着会是更广泛的探索，环游世界，与不同文化背景的人接触吗？我的意思是，我想你一定很擅长这个。让我们所有人接触到世界其他地方和其他……
cultures of people. Yeah, that's a great idea.
We need that. But you know, keep
the meter running feels like a Bordane-esque, like people have said,
this reminds me a Bordane. And subway
it reminds a lot of people of a talk
show like Fallon or Seth Myers or whatever.
So like I kind of get to play in both worlds
and that's really cool. We're doing a live show
人们的文化。是的，这是个好主意。我们需要这个。但你知道，保持仪表盘运转感觉有点像安东尼·波登式的，就像人们说的，这让我想到了波登。而地铁则让很多人联想到 Fallon 或 Seth Myers 那样的脱口秀。所以，我有点像是在两个世界里游刃有余，这真的很酷。我们在办一场现场演出，
for Subway Takes Live which is really fun
and interesting to me.
How would that work?
People come and do what you did except
it's like it's like the audience
is giving the takes and then there's like a panel.
It would be us four on stage and people
would walk up to a mic and say
《地铁观点现场秀》（Subway Takes Live），这对我来说真的很有趣也很吸引人。那会是怎么个运作法呢？人们来做你做过的事，只不过就像是观众给出观点，然后有一个专家小组。就是我们四个人在台上，人们走到麦克风前说，
I think this and then we would all go
no you're you're an idiot blah blah blah blah
That's a great idea, yeah.
Have there ever been,
have there under been some dust-ups there on the train?
Because I remember, you know, we were just,
we were riding on,
we didn't have a shooting permit or anything like that.
我觉得是这样的，然后我们都会说，不，你是个白痴，巴拉巴拉巴拉……这主意真不错，是的。地铁上有没有发生过什么冲突？因为我记得，你知道的，我们当时，我们正在乘车，我们当时没有拍摄许可之类的。
We were just on the train.
Cameras were rolling a couple of cameras,
and these, you know, two guys holding these weird mics and talking,
and somebody might be recognizable.
And have you ever had, like, a weird subway passenger,
like, bother you and your guest?
Not with anyone, like, with anyone famous,
it's always, it's always a pleasure to,
我们只是在地铁上。摄像机在拍，有几个镜头，然后这两个，你知道的，两个家伙拿着奇奇怪怪的麦克风在聊天，而且可能有人能认出我们。你有没有遇到过什么奇怪的地铁乘客，打扰你和你的嘉宾？没有跟任何人起过冲突，跟任何名人在一起时，总是，总是很高兴，
see. Like Woody Harrelson was literally kind of took over the train car and he started interviewing
other people and there were all these people like, and he was just surrounded by people and just
putting this mic in their faces and asking them questions and really creating a circus like in the
car and everyone loved him. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. The timing of
that concept and you and doing all of this is really great because we're at an apex of
like people wanting to connect again.
And so it's probably probably has a lot to do with that.
And the lost art of conversation too.
能看到。就像伍迪·哈里森（Woody Harrelson）literally（简直）有点接管了车厢，他开始采访其他人，有所有这些人在那里，他只是被人群包围着，把这个麦克风塞到他们脸前，问他们问题，真的在车厢里制造了一场马戏团般的狂欢，每个人都非常喜欢他。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。这个概念的时机，以及你所做的一切，真的是太棒了，因为我们正处于人们再次渴望建立联系的巅峰时期。所以这可能很大程度上与此有关。还有谈话艺术的失落。
I mean, everyone's kind of getting all their itches scratched just online and with
their own little devices.
In five second increments.
Yeah, they're not talking to people.
And that's why I always think that the 100% agree, 100% disagree, like there's no middle
for me.
And it is really kind of like an exploration of what it means to,
100% disagree, but still have a funny, casual, engaging conversation.
我的意思是，每个人都只是在网络上和他们的小设备上获得一点点即时满足。以五秒钟为增量。是的，他们不跟人交谈。这就是为什么我总是觉得100%赞成，100%反对，对我来说没有中间地带。这实际上是对以下意义的一种探索，100%反对，但仍然能够进行有趣、随意、引人入胜的对话。
Like, I personally don't really have that many opinions.
Like, I'm pretty mellow.
But in the show, it's like, it's a challenge for me to be like, well, here's why I disagree.
But it's kind of a showcase that you can, yeah, like, have fun doing this.
But there was one funny thing.
It was like a regular episode that I was filming.
And there was a passenger on the train filming us film, which is completely,
fine, like great.
就我个人而言，我其实没有那么多强烈的观点。我挺随和的。但在节目中，这就好像是对我的一种挑战，让我不得不说，好吧，这就是我不同意的原因。但这恰恰展示了你可以，是的，带着乐趣来做这件事。不过有件趣事。那是常规的一集节目，我正在拍摄。车上有一个乘客在拍我们拍摄，这完全没问题，挺好的。
This other guy in the train
slapped the phone out of
that guy's hand and then
kicked it across the car
all the way to the other side.
And then that guy that got
his phone slapped out of his hand looks at me
and he's like, I'm so sorry, dude. And I'm like,
车上的另一个家伙一巴掌把那个人的手机从他手里拍飞了，然后一脚把它踢过车厢，一直踢到了另一边。然后那个手机被打飞的家伙看着我，对我说：“兄弟，太对不起了。”然后我说：
why? And he's like, your bouncer
just kicked the phone out of my hand. And I was
like, that's not my bouncer.
That's just a crazy guy.
For some reason, decided
that you shouldn't film me.
And there was like this confusion where everyone was kind of pointing each other.
Like, whose bodyguard is that?
“为什么？”他说：“你的保镖刚把我的手机从我手里踢飞了。”我说：“那不是我的保镖。那只是个疯子。不知为什么，他决定你不应该拍我。”当时出现了一种混乱，每个人都在互相指责。比如，那是谁的保镖？
Or like, do you guys know each other?
No one knew each other.
It was really funny and, like, confusing.
But that's the closest call.
Did the guy who slapped it, did he ever explain his position as to why he did it?
No, he would just yell something about like Jesus and walked away.
Oh, that makes sense.
That tracks.
或者像，你们认识吗？根本没人认识。真的超级好笑，而且很让人迷惑。不过这就是最惊险的一次了。那个动手打手机的家伙，他后来有没有解释他为什么这么做？没有，他只是大喊了一些关于耶稣之类的话然后就走开了。哦，那说得通。这就对了。
So, wait, but I wanted to ask Will.
Will and Sean, what were your take?
Like, if you were on the show and I said, what's your take?
would your take be? Well, we know Sean's. Something about Rickshaws. Oh, yeah. Sean said the Rickshaw.
Willie, what's, what's about New York? Like, no, no, like I, I, one of my, one of mine is that I think
that the dancing part of the wedding is the worst part. Like, it should just, I didn't even do it.
It should be dinner. At my own wedding. I did, I didn't dance with my wife on our own wedding,
because I hate dancing so much. I didn't know that. I don't know that. Is that true? Yeah, I, I, I,
所以，等等，但我想问问威尔。威尔和肖恩，你们的观点是什么？如果你们上了节目，我说，你们的观点是什么？你们的观点会是什么？好吧，我们知道肖恩的观点。关于人力车的某种观点。哦，对。肖恩说了人力车的事。威尔，你的呢，关于纽约的观点是什么？不，不，就像我，我的其中一个观点是，我觉得婚礼上的跳舞环节是最糟糕的部分。就像，我甚至都没跳。应该只是吃晚饭。在我自己的婚礼上。我甚至没有在自己的婚礼上和妻子跳舞，因为我太讨厌跳舞了。我不知道这个。我不知道这个。真的吗？是的，我，我，
that's how much. At that moment, it's not about you. I'm so uncomfortable, dancing. I don't, I
I know it, but I just, I told her early on.
That is profoundly unkind.
I know, but I just, I couldn't, I couldn't do it.
I'm calling Amanda.
I'm calling Amanda today, and I'm going to take her out dancing.
Yeah, go, go for it.
I encourage it.
就是这么讨厌。在那一刻，这不是关于你自己的。跳舞让我感到非常不自在。我不知道，我，我懂的，但我很早就跟她说过。这未免太不近人情了。我知道，但我就是，我做不到。我要给阿曼达（Amanda）打电话。我今天就要给阿曼达打电话，我要带她去跳舞。行啊，去吧，去吧。我鼓励你这么做。
Go for it.
Please.
I encourage it.
That's so, that, that's, that's, that's a hard line.
But I was saying not at your own wedding, Jason.
I'm saying like, if you, like, it should just end at dinner.
Like, you just go have a great night, everyone.
Thanks for calling the wedding.
去吧。求之不得。我鼓励你。这真是，这真是，这真是个底线。但我的意思是并不是在你自己的婚礼上，杰森。我的意思是，如果你去，它应该在晚饭时就结束。就像，大家吃个开心的夜晚，谢谢光临婚礼。
I 100% agree with that.
And then it's always a force thing.
The DJ is playing like Little John and the East Side Boys from like 2002.
And you're like,
and no one wants to be there.
And yeah.
So that's like,
or like I have another one,
我对此100%赞成。而且那总是个强迫的环节。DJ在放类似小约翰（Lil Jon）和East Side Boys在2002年的歌。然后你就会觉得，而且根本没人想待在那里。然后，是的。所以这就是，或者像我还有另一个观点，
which is that I think,
and this one I think will be problematic.
But like,
I don't like street art and graffiti.
And I would rather just look at like nice,
beautiful buildings.
Okay.
Yeah,
那就是我觉得，这个观点我觉得可能会引起争议。但是，我不喜欢街头艺术和涂鸦。我宁愿只看那些漂亮、美丽的建筑。好吧。是的，
but a lot of people are going to get mad at me for that.
What?
Really?
People are.
Yeah.
Great defenders of graffiti?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Street art graffiti.
但是很多人会因为这个生我的气。什么？真的吗？人们会的。是的。涂鸦的狂热捍卫者？哦，对，对，对。街头艺术涂鸦。
Aside from the people that actually do it,
you're saying people that just observe it are big fans of it?
I think so.
I think that there's a cohort of people that think that it's like, it's nice, yeah.
I enjoy it, yeah.
See?
I have too many, but all of mine get me in trouble.
All of mine are terrible.
除了那些实际创作它的人之外，你是说只是观察它的人也是它的超级粉丝？我想是的。我认为有一群人觉得这很不错，是的。我挺喜欢的，是的。你看？我有太多观点了，但我的所有观点都会给我惹麻烦。我的观点都很糟糕。
First of all, I think I should be deputized to be able to give out,
just to the parking part of the police department.
I'd love to give out.
Oh, you would love to give a ticket.
I'd love to give out tickets and also moving vehicle tickets.
That's a good idea of citizens.
And I also think that we should be able to report when like, you know, like when like the cops who do a great job,
but when they pull people over and then they obstruct traffic and it's unnecessary.
首先，我觉得我应该被授权成为警察局交通部门的一员，哪怕只是负责停车违章。我很乐意去开罚单。哦，你肯定很乐意开罚单。我很乐意开罚单，还有行驶中的车辆违章罚单。这是个不错的公民责任感的主意。而且我还认为，我们应该能够举报那些，你知道的，比如那些工作很出色的警察，但当他们把车停靠盘查，阻碍了交通而且完全没有必要的时候。
Yeah, they don't need to hang out into the other lane.
I mean, I guess they're doing that to protect themselves as they're up at the window.
But why don't you go around to the passenger window and then you don't have to hang out in the traffic.
I don't even mean on a freeway or anything.
I mean, like, you're in New York.
You know, you're in New York, but although I'm, so I don't want to criticize NYPD because I do, I do, it's a rough, tough job.
It would be nice if they deputized us to give out maybe three citizen tickets for moving violations a month, you know, so you can't abuse it.
You just get three.
对，他们没必要把车身探到另一个车道上。我的意思是，他们这么做可能是为了在走到车窗边时保护自己。但你为什么不绕到副驾驶的车窗那边呢，这样你就不用把身子探到车流里了。我甚至都不是指在高速公路或什么地方。我是指在纽约。你知道的，你在纽约，不过虽然我是，所以我不想批评纽约警察局（NYPD），因为我确实，我确实觉得这是一份极其艰难的工作。如果他们能授权我们每个月发放大概三张针对行车违章的公民罚单，那就太好了，这样你就不会滥用权力。你只有三张。
So the three most egregious things you see when you're driving, you're allowed to put the little cojack light on on top of your car and go get them.
I think it would be nice if you could also get Sean's, like if Sean wanted to ticket the loud.
rickshaw guys.
Yeah.
You could give,
like,
we should all be active,
citizen.
所以当你开车时看到的三个最令人发指的行为，你被允许在车顶上放那个警用爆闪灯，然后去追他们。我觉得如果能加上肖恩的那种权利就更好了，比如肖恩想给那些吵闹的人力车夫开罚单。对。你可以发，就像，我们都应该成为积极的公民。
Like, why don't we have a little bit of power?
We're taping people anyway.
We might as well be able to use it to...
But then I thought about,
here's the flip of it.
I was thinking about this yesterday.
And then I'm like,
how many yellows have I squeezed
为什么我们不能有一点点权力呢？反正我们也在拍别人。我们不妨利用它来……但后来我想到了，这就是反面。我昨天还在想这个。然后我想，我在开车通过十字路口时，抢了多少次黄灯？我想，我自己也并非免疫。所以后来我有点打退堂鼓了。不过我，天哪，我对这些破事有太多的观点了。我确实有。等等，有两个我只是没有。一个是，我不知道这在Instagram上是不是个假帖子，
while driving through an intersection?
I'm like, and I'm not immune from it myself.
And so then I kind of walked it back.
But I have, God, I have so many takes on shit.
I do.
Wait, there's two that I just don't have.
One is, I don't know if this is a fake post
on Instagram or not,
但我看到报道说纽约正在考虑制定一项法律，考虑立法像规划街道一样规划人行道，让走得快的人走在左边，我觉得这真的是个绝妙的主意。
but I read that New York.
is looking into making a law,
looking into making it a law
to traffic the sidewalks
like they do the streets
so that fast people walkers
walk on the left,
which I think is really a great idea.
哦，特别是在纽约，当人们突然停在街道中间而你却说，嘿，老兄，而且还一边盯着手机，这真的很让人沮丧。或者人们在人行道上横着四个人并排走。你根本无法绕过他们。比如，如果你是一个两人生以上的群体，你们必须得排成两列，或者单列纵队。
Oh, especially in New York, it's a bummer
when people stop in the middle of the street
and you're like, hey man, and also watching their phone.
Or people walk four wide on a sidewalks.
You can't get around people.
Like, if you're a group of more than two,
you have to go kind of two by two,
kind of single-fime.
这是我的激进观点。这就是我的想法。如果你想在互联网上发布任何东西，评论，随便什么，任何内容，我们必须知道你的名字。还有你的脸。你的住址、电话号码。还有你的脸。不再有匿名。再也没有匿名了。
Here's my hot say.
Here's what I think.
If you want to post anything on the internet, comment, whatever, anything, we have to know your name.
And your face.
Your address, your phone number.
No anonymous.
No anonymous anymore.
我认为这会，我认为这会立刻改变世界。立刻。我必须这样做。如果每个人，你必须这样做，必须有记录。我们知道他们可以做到，因为，你知道，像区块链这样的技术，你可以追踪绝对所有的一切，什么都知道。所以如果我们把同样的逻辑应用到那上面。所以你不能上任何网站，你不能发表任何评论。你可以，但我们知道你的名字、住址、电话号码。
And I think that that would, I think it would change the world immediately.
Immediately.
I have to.
If everybody, you have to, there is a record.
And we know that they can do it because, you know, things like the blockchain where you can trace absolutely everything where you know.
So if we applied that same logic to that.
So you can't go on to anything, you can't make any comment.
You can, but we know your name, your address, your phone number.
通过这些，我们就能推断出你在哪里工作，你的家人是谁，诸如此类的所有事情。你要承担责任，因为如果我发表评论，每个人都知道我是谁。然后我就得承担起这种其他人根本不需要承担的疯狂的高标准。对。但等等，这是我的另一个观点，杰森前天晚上对我说过，
And by that we'll be able to decipher where you work, who your family is, all that sort of stuff.
And you are held, so that because if I make a comment, everybody knows who I am.
And so then I get held up to this crazy high standard that everybody else has not held up to.
Yeah.
But wait, here's my other take is Jason commented on me the other night.
when we were at dinner, that when you order a dessert for yourself,
and then the waitress comes over with spoons for everybody at the table,
and you're like, wait, no, everybody passed on ordering dessert.
当我们去吃晚饭时，当你给自己点了一份甜点，然后女服务员走过来，给桌上的每个人都发了一把勺子，而你却说，等等，不，大家都略过了没点甜点。我点了甜点，当被问到时，其他所有人都说，不，我很好，我不想吃甜点。然后每个人都开始用勺子狂挖你他妈的甜点。好观点。我说，不，去点你自己的甜点吧。对。就像，我点了我自己的。如果你没有选择参与，你就没有资格用勺子。
I ordered dessert, and when offered, everybody else's like,
no, I'm good, I don't want a dessert.
And then everybody spoons the shit out of your fucking dessert.
Good take.
I'm like, no, get your own dessert.
Right.
Like, I did.
If you did not opt in, you don't get a spoon.
除非事先说明，给我们来个圣代，然后给每个人一把勺子。没错。除此之外，不行。别用勺子挖。向欧迪昂餐厅（Odeon）致敬。还记得我们在那儿吗，前天晚上我们在欧迪昂餐厅。
Unless it was specified, bring us the Sunday.
and bring everybody a spoon.
That's right.
Otherwise, no.
Don't do this spoon.
Shout out to Odeon.
Remember we had that,
so we did have that the other night at the Odeon.
对。我点了这个，我点了甜点是因为我说，我想来一份圣代。结果就像是，噢，我说，每个人都点自己的甜点吧。
Right.
And I would,
and I ordered this,
I started because I said,
I want to get a Sunday.
And it was like, ooh,
and I go,
everybody gets your own dessert.
你不能来抢我的。没错。没错。你几乎得当众宣布才行。你得宣布。哦，太搞笑了。对。杰森，杰森当时就像是，
You're not for fucking.
That's right.
You almost have to announce it this week.
You have to announce it.
Oh, that's so funny.
Yeah.
And Jason, Jason was like,
别点甜甜圈。我点了两份甜甜圈。他妈的，他的脸直接埋在两份里了。你还真是不客气。我吃了六个。现在，卡里姆，伴随着这一切真正酷炫、实至名归的成功，在你那假设中非常接地气的老百姓生活中，有什么改变吗？你有没有，威尔刚才开玩笑说你……
don't get the donuts.
I got two orders of donuts.
He fucking, his face was buried in both.
You did bless you.
I had six of them.
Now, Kareem, with all of this really cool, very well-deserved success,
what has changed in your, I'm presuming, very sort of down-to-earth, man-of-the-people life?
Have you, Will joked earlier that you...
比如升级了你的空调？对吧。还是说依然用胶带贴在窗户上，缠着红胶带？看那个。别担心。好吧，当我安装这个的时候，我还有另一个重大的观点。当时我就想，他们在纽约居然允许我这么做，这太令人震惊了。如果我的空调是用胶带粘着的，那就意味着还有，然后我开始环顾四周，
Like, upgraded your air conditioner?
Right.
Or is it still tape to the window and red tape?
Look at that.
Don't worry about it.
Well, that's another big take that I have when I was installing this.
I was like, it is shocking that they let me do this in New York.
And if I'm taping mine, that means that there, and then I started looking around,
有的人的空调是用书本撑着的。有些人用一块小木头。然后我想，这居然没有统一的标准操作程序。我同意。我同意。是的，那边有个家伙用了几本教科书。我能看见。我想，这太可怕了，因为现在我走在纽约街头，脑子里总会浮现出我自己
there's like people that their air conditioners are being held up by books.
Some people have a little piece of wood.
And I'm like, there's not a standard processing.
I agree.
Yeah, there's a guy over there that has a couple of textbook.
I can see.
I'm like, and it's so scary because now I can't walk around New York City without thinking about my own self
安装空调的情景，而且你们显然能看出我干得有多好。我懂。我记得卡里姆，第一次我在纽约的窗户上装空调时心想，这他妈简直是疯了。这玩意儿随时可能掉下去。我刚装好这个。
putting in my air conditioner,
and you guys obviously see how good of a job I've done.
I know.
I remember Kreme,
the first time I put an air conditioner in my window in New York
and thinking, this is freaking lunacy.
This can go at any time.
I just did this.
我简直是个白痴，这东西随时会掉下去砸死个人。而且窗户本身也不怎么样。窗户很不结实。窗户非常不结实。它们基本上是用保鲜膜做成的。这简直太吓人了，
I'm an idiot,
and this thing is going to fall on somebody and kill somebody.
And it's not like the windows are nice.
The windows are flimsy.
The windows are flimsy windows.
They're made out of saran wrap, essentially.
And it's just terrifying.
and there's no screws.
而且没有螺丝。完全没有，没有工具。没有。这基本上就是靠窗户本身把它卡在原位的。所以你还没有升级到主流空调。你奖励了自己什么？我的意思是，对于我该以什么为生，我生活中的焦虑少了很多。
None of this, there's no tools.
No.
This is just like the windows holding in the place.
So you haven't,
so you haven't gone to mainstream air conditioning.
What, what have you treated yourself to?
I mean, I, there's a lot less anxiety in my life
about what I'm supposed to be doing for a living.
这真的很吓人，因为我开始做这个的时候已经33岁了，比许多人都要晚，比如很多喜剧演员或者社交媒体上的孩子们。你知道的，他们通常22岁、21岁、25岁就开始了。他们大学时就在即兴表演社团。所以从33岁开始，
And that is really scary because I also started doing this when I was 33,
which is later than many people,
like many comedians or these social media kids.
You know, they start when they're like 22,
who 21, 25.
They were in their college
improv group.
So to start at 33
并且进行了一场如此巨大的豪赌，最后竟然成功了，这太令人震惊了。每天我都觉得……这太棒了。太棒了。这并不震惊。一点也不震惊。
and take like this massive bet
and then have it work out,
it's shocking.
And every day I'm just like...
It's dope.
It's not shocking.
你是个聪明人，而且你真的很有趣。我……当别人问你……你不会自称是创作者吧？不，不，不。
You're a smart guy
and you are really funny.
And I...
Do you refer to yourself
as when people say,
what do you...
You don't say creator, do you?
No, no, no.
我自称是艺人。因为我还制作了……我写了一部电影，制片，并且主演了它。那部电影在 Mooby 上上映了。我做音乐。那个叫什么来着？我是一个摇滚乐队的成员。
I say entertainer.
Because I also made...
I wrote a movie,
produced it, starred in it.
That's out on movie.
I make music.
What's that called?
I'm in a rock and roll band.
那部电影叫《或者别的什么》（Or Something）。或者别的什么。这是一部故事片。这是我的第一部长片。我们能在哪里看到它？在 Mooby 上，M-U-B-I。M-U-B-I。好的。
The movie's called Or Something.
Or something.
And it's a feature film.
It's my first feature.
And we can find that where?
On Mooby, M-U-B-I.
M-U-B-I.
Okay.
就像 T-B-B-B-W-A。我是 M-B-E-B-B-E 吗？然后你说，你还在一个乐队里？不。对，我在一个叫“微型枪”（Tiny Gun）的摇滚乐队里。太棒了。你在唱歌？你在打鼓？
That's like T-B-B-B-W-A.
Do I have M-B-E-B-B-E?
And then you say, you're in a band, too?
No.
Yeah, I'm in a rock-and-roll band called Tiny Gun.
That's amazing.
Are you singing?
Are you drumming?
还是在弹吉他？我唱歌。是的。哇。对，对。这有点像朋克，有点像小精灵乐队（Pixies）。我们爱小精灵乐队。小精灵乐队碰上鼓击乐队（The Strokes）的那种风格。
Are you guitaring?
I sing.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
And it's kind of like a punk, like, Pixies.
We love pixies.
The pixies meets the strokes kind of situation.
是的，挺酷的。说到我的心坎上了。对，听听看吧。微型枪（Tiny Gun）。Tondi。Hondo P. 我们在外地音乐节（Outside Lands）演出过。去年我们在外地音乐节
Yeah, that's cool.
Speaking my language.
Yeah, give us a listen.
Tiny gun.
Tondi.
Hondo P.
We played outside land.
Last year we played outside lands
和纽波特民谣节（Newport Folk Festival）上演出过。真的很有趣。是的。你们听到那些警笛声了吗？听到了，很难忽略。是的，它们能让空调兴奋起来。好吧，是的，那是开罚单的声音。是肖恩。
in Newport Folk Festival.
It was really fun.
Yeah.
Do you guys hear those sirens?
Yeah, it's hard not to.
Yeah, they can excite the air conditioner.
Well, yeah, that's a ticket.
It's Sean.
是威尔和肖恩。肖恩坐着那个人力车。杰森·贝特曼骑着他的摩托车。老实说，我真的被你做过那么多不同的事情以及你同时进行了多少次有创意的尝试所启发。我觉得这太棒了。我认为这，你正在做我刚才一直在谈论的那件事，我希望自己能做更多的事。
It's Will and Sean.
Sean on this Rickshaw.
It's Jason Bateman on his motorcycle.
I'm so, honestly, I'm so inspired by how much different stuff you do
and how many creative swings you take at once.
I think it's awesome.
I think that that is, you're doing the very thing that I was talking about,
that I wish I could do more.
你在冒险，你以一种如此棒的方式融入生活。我觉得这酷毙了。这里面也有一些文化相关性和对社会的帮助，对吧？太棒了。太棒了。这真的很酷。你们是，从你们嘴里说出这种话，感觉真是一个巨大的赞美。不，但你并没有迎合最低的共同标准。
You're taking chances and you're engaging in life in such an awesome way.
I think it's dope as hell.
There's some cultural relevance and help to it as well, right?
It's amazing.
It's really cool.
You guys are, that feels like it's such a compliment coming from you guys.
No, but you're not catering to the lowest common.
而且你试图做的事情，不一定是在某种意义上是崇高的，比如，你知道的，拯救人类。但从某种意义上说，你确实在参与其中，保持对话的进行，引发思考，而且，我不知道，我觉得这真的很酷。把人们聚集在一起。这只是一种经典的在你的智商巅峰进行创作的局势，我觉得因为很多人没有这样做，所以我想，不如让我变得稍微不同一点，
And like you're trying to do stuff that,
not necessarily sort of worthy in the sense of, like, you know, helping humanity.
But you are in a way, you are sort of engaging and keeping conversation going
and provoking thought and just, I don't know, I think it's really rad.
Bringing folks together.
It's just that classic playing at the top of your intelligence situation,
which I feel like because so many people are not doing that,
I was like, let me just be a little bit different
并努力成为这种东西所能达到的最聪明版本，而这种东西是有局限的，比如手机、小屏幕、竖屏，让我试着做到尽可能聪明。而且你没有穿着比基尼泳裤到处招摇。你知道我的意思吗？试图看……你们可不想看到我穿比基尼泳裤。
and try to be the smartest version.
of what this thing limits you to,
which is a phone, tiny screen,
vertical, like, let me try to do the smartest thing possible.
And you're not prancing around in a speedo.
You know what I mean?
Trying to see...
You don't want to see me in a speedo.
等等，我在哪里能看到这个？而且自私地说，你给了我们这些笨蛋一个非常棒、有趣且富有创造力的宣传站点，让我们在宣传巡回演出时去和大家交流。是的，我想邀请你们上节目。我想去……我想做……
Wait, where do I find that?
And selfishly, you're giving us ding-dongs
that are like promoting stuff
this really great, fun, creative stop
on our press tours to go talk to folks.
Yeah, I want to have you guys on.
I want to come to...
I want to do...
我想把你们三个同时请来。哦，那绝对太火爆了。但问题是。杰森做过了。为了胜过他，我当然想这么做。理所当然。双倍奉还。当然。
I would have all three of you on at the same time.
Oh, that would be lit.
But here's the thing.
Jason did it.
I want to do just to one-up him, obviously.
Of course.
Double up.
双倍奉还。四分钟。不，下次你来纽约时，我们一定得安排你上节目。我随时奉陪。我会去的。我一半的时间都在那儿。太棒了。
Double app.
Four minutes.
No, let's get you out.
Let's get you next time you're in New York.
I'm there.
I'll be there.
I'll be there half the time.
Great.
那我在字面意义上的任何时间都可以。比如，我会走出家门，你知道的。我们能坐一号线吗？可以吗？是的，我正想说，你的地铁是哪一路？那到底是什么鬼东西？你知道的，他们管那叫什么来着？现在的“一号线”？
Then I will do it at literally any time.
Like, I'll step out of the house, you know.
Can we take the one-nine?
Is that okay?
Yeah, I was going to say, what would be your subway?
What the hell's that?
You know, like, what do they call it?
The one now?
以前西区叫一号线九号线，你知道的，红线。哦，我从来没去过那边。真的吗？我是东区的人。我们也可以走东区。就像，不，不，不，不，我去找你。我来找你。不，我们坐六号线。
It used to be the one-nine on the west side, you know, the red line.
Oh, I've never been over there.
Really?
I'm an east side guy.
We can do the east side too.
It's like, no, no, no, no, I'll come to you.
I'll come to you.
No, we'll take the six.
那也行。不，不，不，不，还是我来找你。管他呢，我坐F线。我才不管呢。等等，我还想说一件事，所以，这跟我们谈论的话题无关，虽然某种程度上也算有关，但是，说回正题，我可不是在自吹自擂，自吹自擂，吹我自己的笛子。我可不是在吹我自己的笛子。
That's fine.
No, no, no, no, come to you.
But fuck it, I'll take the F.
I don't give you shit.
Wait, I also want to say something that, so I, this has nothing to do with what we're talking about,
although it kind of does, but like, going back, I don't want to tout my own horn,
to my own horn, toot my own flute.
I don't want to tut my own flute.
但我还是要在这里说一下，以防艾美奖的任何人，他们叫什么来着，学院派？当然。没错，我们要去了。《地铁观点》要冲刺艾美奖了。是吗？好的。所以请予以考虑，请予以考虑，太棒了。
But I want to say this here in case anyone from the Emmy, what are they called, the Academy?
Sure.
Yeah, we're going.
Subway Takes is going for an Emmy.
Is it?
Okay.
So for your consideration, for your consideration,
Great.
《地铁观点》。但等等，那它必须在电视上播出吗？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢你刚才说的那句话了。不，他们现在有小奖杯了。迷你艾美奖？给你颁个迷你艾美奖。那不叫威比奖（Webby）吗？
Subway takes.
But wait, but does it got to be on the telly then?
I love that.
I love that you just said that.
No, they have little ones now.
Tiny Emmys?
Tiny Emmys for your boy.
Isn't that called a Webby?
不，这是创意艺术艾美奖。你可以凭借短片获得创意艺术艾美奖。是的，就像，你知道的，这个环节很火？比如，比如，比如，车上卡拉OK（Carpool Karaoke），对吧。或者那个吃辣翅的家伙？是的，《热辣对话》（Hot Ones）的肖恩·埃文斯。所以，好吧，所以，所以，所以，所以，卡里姆，为了把话说清楚，如果你恰好在听这个节目，而且你恰好是电视艺术与科学学院的投票人，
No, it's a creative, the creative arts Emmy.
You can get a creative arts Emmy for like short form.
Yeah, like, you know, this a bit's a lot?
Like, like, like, like, carpool karaoke, right.
Or the dude with the hot wings?
Yes, Sean Evans from Hot Ones.
So, okay, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, Creme, to be clear, if you, if you happen to be
listening to this and you are a voter in the Television Academy,
不，这是一个创意艺术艾美奖。你可以因为短片之类的获得创意艺术艾美奖。是的，就像，你知道，这个环节有很多？比如，拼车K歌秀，对吧。或者那个吃辣翅的家伙？对，Hot Ones的肖恩·埃文斯。所以，好吧，所以，克雷姆，坦白说，如果你恰好在听这个节目，而且你是电视艺术与科学学院的投票人，
check out consider.
Please check out Creme's show.
and consider.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
And then you're tiny,
tiny gun to listen to.
去看看吧。请去看看克里姆的节目，考虑一下。谢谢。谢谢大家。然后你们小小的枪去听。
Guys,
I'm still out here doing this.
I'm still out here shilling for myself.
I mean, I love it.
No one else is going to do it.
Good for you.
I have this opportunity.
Let me,
伙计们，我还在这里做这件事。我还在这里为自己吆喝。我是说，我喜欢。没有别人会这么做了。真为你高兴。我有这个机会，让我，
let me,
I want to see you guys there,
first of all.
And when we see each other there,
we should hug.
Oh, at the Emmys.
Yeah.
Oh, if we're at the Emmys,
让我，首先我希望在那里看到你们。当我们相聚在那里的时候，我们应该拥抱。哦，在艾美奖上。是的。哦，如果我们去艾美奖的话，
we're going to hug like hell.
Yeah.
Yep.
That's all hot.
That's a phrase, right?
Hug.
I want to like you like hell.
I want a hug like hell.
我们要狠狠地拥抱。是的。没错。这太火辣了。这也是个词，对吧？拥抱。我想像疯了一样喜欢你。我想狠狠地拥抱一下。
That was a really good take about men
is that we haven't standardized our creeding.
So, like, I might go up to Will with a hand up in the air,
like, what's good, man, I get to see you?
I might extend a hand to Jason,
and then he's, and it's confusing or a hug Sean.
And it's, yeah, and it's really confusing.
We need a standard.
关于男人的一个很好的看法是，我们还没有规范我们的问候方式。所以，比如说，我可能会举起手走到威尔面前，就像，最近怎么样，兄弟，很高兴见到你？我可能会向杰森伸出手，然后他，这很令人困惑，或者拥抱肖恩。是的，这真的很令人困惑。我们需要一个标准。
My buddy years ago, Ali Farnakian used to say,
you always start road to the White House,
which is just a handshake,
and then anywhere you want to go after that.
But you always start Road to the White House.
This is good advice.
So you extend the hand.
Always extend the hand.
我的死党阿里·法尔纳基安几年前常说，你总是从“通往白宫之路”开始，这只是一次握手，然后你想去哪里就去哪里。但你总是从“通往白宫之路”开始。这是个好建议。所以你伸出手。永远伸出手。
This is called Road to the White House.
Be open to getting pulled in.
And then wherever you want.
Okay.
I always love that.
You should consider driving a cab.
That's a really good cab.
Like that's kind of cab driver advice that I guess.
这叫“通往白宫之路”。对被吸引过去保持开放态度。然后随你所愿。好吧。我一直很喜欢这个。你应该考虑开出租车。那真的是个很好的出租车。这有点像出租车司机的建议，我猜。
Hey, man, it might get to that.
Kareem, we are thrilled to have you.
We love you.
We root for you.
We're watching you.
Keep it going, my friend.
Thank you guys so much.
This was really, really fun.
嘿，老兄，可能会发展到那一步。卡里姆，我们很高兴有你来。我们爱护你。我们支持你。我们在看着你。坚持下去，我的朋友。非常感谢你们，伙计们。这真的，真的很开心。
and I appreciate you guys letting me be on your show.
Seriously.
We'll see you.
We'll see you that there in the city.
We'll see you on the show.
I'll see you on the show.
I can't wait for it.
Thanks, Kareem.
我很感激你们让我上你们的节目。说真的。我们回头见。我们在那里的城市见。我们在节目里见。我会在节目里见到你。我已经等不及了。谢谢你，卡里姆。
Okay, bye, guys.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Thanks out.
Thank you so much for having me.
You got it.
Shaking your hand, goodbye.
Digital shake.
好的，再见，伙计们。谢谢。祝你们过得愉快。谢谢大家的到来。不客气。跟你握手，再见。数字握手。
There he goes.
Kareem.
Rama.
He's good.
He's so good.
Kareem Rama, yeah.
Really great, dude.
Shani, did you invite you on the show?
他走了。卡里姆。拉马。他很好。他太棒了。卡里姆·拉马，是的。真是个好家伙，老兄。肖尼，是你邀请你上节目的吗？
Yeah, I noticed that right there at the end.
You know, I was thinking.
I think he's worried about your safety.
I think that that was that.
By the way, I've never rode on the subway.
Hang on a second.
So maybe that's...
I'm trying to do my...
是的，我刚才在最后注意到了。你知道的，我在想。我觉得他在担心你的安全。我想就是那个。顺便说一句，我从来没坐过地铁。等一下。所以也许那是...我在努力做我的...
I can't believe that face.
I'm trying to...
Hang on.
Sean, that's true, isn't it?
That is very true, yeah.
Is that really true?
Never once on the subway in New York City.
我在努力做我的...我简直不敢相信那个表情。我在努力...等一下。肖恩，那是真的，对吧？那是千真万确的，是的。真的假的？在纽约市一次都没坐过地铁。
I mean, if I did, maybe once 25 years ago, but I don't remember it.
It's not on purpose.
It just hasn't happened.
I just don't feel...
I'd just rather take a cap.
Oh, so it is on purpose?
Yeah, yeah, it's totally on purpose.
I don't even know how they work.
我是说，如果我坐过，也许是25年前的一次，但我记不清了。我不是故意的。只是还没发生过。我只是不觉得...我宁愿坐出租车。哦，所以你是故意的？对，对，完全是故意的。我甚至不知道它们是怎么运作的。
I don't even remember where they are.
There is so...
I will give you...
It is a hack
because you spend a lot more time
in New York these days.
If you have to...
You get anywhere in like two seconds.
我甚至不记得它们在哪里。有这么...我给你提个醒...这算是个小窍门，因为你这些天在纽约呆的时间多得多。如果你必须...你能在两秒钟内到达任何地方。
But now it works with your navigation app,
like Waze or Google Maps
or Apple Mets or whatever it is,
you can just say, you know,
how do I get there via walking,
via car, or via subway?
And then when you hit the subway thing,
it'll give you a little map
但现在它可以通过你的导航软件运行，比如Waze、谷歌地图或苹果地图之类的，你只需说，你知道的，我怎么去那里，步行，开车，还是坐地铁？然后当你点击地铁那个选项时，它会给你一张小地图
how to walk to the subway, what to do?
But it's overwhelming to me
because there's...
Aren't there like 75,000...
But it tells you with...
It'll walk you.
Yeah, it'll tell you what to do.
If you don't know it, it'll tell you what to do.
告诉你怎么走到地铁站，该做什么？但这对我很压抑，因为有...难道没有大约75,000个...但它会指引你。是的，它会告诉你该做什么。如果你不知道，它会告诉你该做什么。
And I'm telling you, you can save yourself hours of being stuck in a freaking car or a cat.
It's so good.
And it's so safe.
Like what?
All right.
Well, that's a little bit of that too, yeah.
It is great.
All right.
我告诉你，你可以省下几个小时被困在令人抓狂的汽车或出租车里的时间。太棒了。而且非常安全。就像什么？好吧。好吧，这也有那么一点点，是的。真的很棒。好吧。
We'll do it together because I love riding on them.
We'll do it next time I'm there.
All right.
We'll hold hands all the way through it.
But you guys should check out those two shows.
Very good.
Yeah, I will.
I've seen a couple of his clips on, on Instagram.
我们一起去吧，因为我喜欢坐地铁。我下次去的时候我们一起去。好吧。我们要一路手拉手。但你们应该去看看那两个节目。非常好。是的，我会的。我看到过他的一些Instagram短片。
And they're always funny and engaging.
So funny.
Like, like you see.
said Jason, it's really interesting that he started, well, you both said it, that he started
something out of like, you know, who would have thought that just conversation would be
interesting to people, you know, like, well, I will say this, I think that there probably
are, Sean, a lot of people who think, like, hey, I'm interesting and I could just do, I'm going
to do a talk show or I'm going to do a thing. And the truth was that he did have an actual
它们总是那么有趣和引人入胜。太搞笑了。就像，就像你说的，杰森，这真的很有趣，他开始了一件，你知道的，谁会想到仅仅是对话就会对人们有趣呢，你知道的，比如说，嗯，我要这么说，我想可能有很多，肖恩，很多人认为，嘿，我很有趣，我可以只做，我要做一个脱口秀节目或者我要做一件事。而事实是，他确实有实际的
a talent for it and that he is an engaging person. And he's very authentic and real.
Very authentic.
Yeah, you know exactly.
That's the key.
Yeah, you just know who he is.
Yeah.
And I bet he could do it.
He could probably take it on the road.
这方面的天赋，而且他是一个很有吸引力的人。他非常真实。非常真实。是的，你知道得很清楚。这就是关键。是的，你就是知道他是谁。是的。我打赌他能做到。他甚至可以去巡回演出。
He could go overseas.
He could do it.
He could definitely do one in Egypt because he was born in Egypt.
So I'd assume that he is by.
Lingwool.
Very good.
Bye.
Smartless.
他可以去海外。他能做到。他绝对可以在埃及做一场，因为他是在埃及出生的。所以我猜他懂双语。非常好。再见。Smartless。
Smartless is 100% organic.
And artisanly handcraft.
by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
Smart. Less.
Smartless 是100%纯天然、由罗布·阿姆贾夫、本·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的节目。Smart Less。